uh-oh oh man this is so awesome
okay now yeah now queen eight you came
back to v8 and Bob's your uncle
okay wait a minute what okay no there
there is no idea of bringing the King
forward with some sort of made on a
seven because black Queens with check on
she won because even here you can't take
that harm
there's always pushing p7
wait a sec
wait a second we nee J
oh my gosh oh my gosh acara plundered it
Oh
oh my gosh and he's smiling and he's
just like oh oh oh she that you could
see Maxime start bouncing I started as
soon as the king went to a it I was like
wait a second Renate jade is a very holy
shenanigans and Joshua Chamberlain truly
does strike again
[Music]
and then there was one matchup left in
the 2018 speech as championship
quarterfinals it's all come down to the
1 seed overall Hikaru Nakamura versus
the 8 seed overall though as many people
feel mr. Hamilton you could argue that
the winner of this match today is the is
the favor to take the whole thing so as
we look at Hikaru Nakamura versus Maxine
Bosh magrav what are your thoughts about
these two super grandmasters and just
powerhouse GM's in this online format
and and how excited are you to be here
today buddy what's up Danny and hello to
everyone watching yeah as you said I
mean this on paper has to be pretty much
everyone's marquee matchup I found the
speed chess championship to be pretty
exciting even in matchups that you might
not expect I found every round to be
pretty exciting and I don't think we're
gonna be disappointed here but these
guys have played on chess calm in
matchups before many times
hello they're very familiar with each
other and NAFTA Mora has consistently
gotten the upper hand so you know will
will he continue that in this match
Maxine really has has a lot to prove
ya know you're you're absolutely right
these guys have a long history about as
long of a history as anybody or any
matchup in our format right those those
og chess calm followers for the last
five plus years remember our original
what we used to just say the Blitz
deathmatch which we still do kind of in
the offseason of the SEC and then we had
the original grandmaster blitz battle
championship and now last year's SEC and
as you said the karo has won every
single one of those matchups so he has a
300 perfect score in this sort of who's
the best blitz and bullet player overall
but you know Maxime continues to get
better right he continues to close that
gap I guess as far as the over the board
chest goes and so when and how that
translates to him really pushing pushing
Nakamura to the limit we'll find out
maybe that's today yeah and I'm not sure
that that's a product of necessarily a
car getting worse bye
it's really hard when you're you know
regarded as one of the best if not the
best right
you know you're just constantly looking
and everyone else is catching up to you
slowly this is really hard to improve
when when you're right at the top no
absolutely and I I think you you said it
best I think it's hard it's hard to go
anywhere when you're on top and of
course Maxime has has gotten better
right he's a few years younger than
Hikaru and continues to improve we can
see right here that as far as feed a
blitz goes in our pre-match smarter
chess predictions Maxime is actually the
higher rated currently feed a blitz
player that didn't know that actually it
really doesn't mean it really doesn't
mean much as far as at least as far as
are smarter chess predictions go I think
because we know these guys in their
history stylistically maybe it gives
Hikaru even more of an edge sometimes it
gets Maxine but again this is all talk
until we just see what what goes down
but as we've said these are that these
two guys have a long history this is our
final order Finals matchup and after
this we will find out who is officially
moving on into the finals the finals of
course will be November 30th through
December 2nd that's this year so right
after this small event going down in
London a championship match between a
couple of jokers we don't really know we
don't talk about it no getting we
haven't we have the the speech Chess
Championship finals going down so mark
your calendars this is your last match
until we until we move into the finals
already about a thousand of you with us
here or shout out to the the lovely
chess Bay we see you NC liquid ed
product he was our first donator on
Tuesday when so managed to take down
Gujarati on his birthday so thank you to
everybody who's here but I said hey yes
the shout out to them shout out to
everybody and well I gave you a quick
preview I will remind you that is
something we wanted to let everybody
know about today on October 14th yours
truly will be hosting the one the first
of its kind a hand and brain chess event
with some Poker Stars some faces for
those of you who know the poker world
even if you don't know the poker world
you're probably aware of who Daniel
Negreanu is and Liv Boeree is also a
well-known poker commodity so who's the
hand who's the brain Danny but it'll be
the stronger players is the brain I
think that kind of sometimes sends the
the
the game in a slightly higher level
direction and then so Jen and I will
recommend pieces and they will get to
then choose what move that actually
accumulates to but all right for today
we've got Maxine washing over Nicola
Nakamura hey Carl look at that I'm on
sporting some new sexy glasses he looks
he looks is he about to climb behind a
Starfighter and go battle the Death Star
I mean is he yeah once I hook Skywalker
there or what I saw I saw the glasses go
on pregame and he almost had a look on
his face like he knew what he was up to
he's ready for the comments I mean I
don't know it's gonna take me a while to
to really generate some good ones but
I'm slowly accustoming myself to it and
I'm gonna have some good comments yeah
well I I went with my first gut there
with the Star Wars reference maybe that
was a little bit a little bit too soon
but either way we're gonna get this
thing underway the players are set we
are set officially the first move has
been made and you and I my friend get to
enjoy the next few hours of our life
watching some awesome chefs so so d4 how
does that how does that make your hair
feel how's your hair feeling by the way
we haven't talked about that yet
it's feeling purple Danny you know and
you know it's nice because when when you
have purple hair and you play poorly in
the Olympiad people still take photos of
you anyway because of your hair right so
I have the media around me and I get to
feel very important even though that the
games are over well you're important to
us and I think this is the most viewers
we've had to start a match so again
thank you everybody who's here reminder
any and all donations go directly to the
the players that you see playing we will
we will be diving into the analysis here
so an a a grünfeld
the theory is has already happened and
Hikaru doing his vintage place so fast I
have more time than that which I started
with already over five minutes yeah he's
he's a massing almost a one-minute
advantage here and he's gone for what I
would definitely consider a fairly
unorthodox move Bishop g5 I'm who's
seven so you this is I've seen it before
but I very rare
to me he's putting immediate pressure on
e7 but I think most people would feel
pretty loose with that Bishop way out
there on g5 not contributing to
defending the center and when the grin
felled is based completely on black
assaulting the center which is what he's
doing here but immediately puts pressure
on d4 of course the whole point of the
opening is that you have to basically
push that pawn it's very hard to
maintain Knight f3 gets met by Bishop g4
so this idea of d4 d5 with the bishop on
g5 is clearly part of the the opening it
makes me wonder i Hikaru can do a lot of
different things in these matches we see
him play his vintage kind of be free
sort of double fianchettoed ready style
systems right I mean you've you've had
some games against him in that and
normally from my perspective we see him
play more unorthodox though free here I
say go play F 3 and then Bishop well you
can you can even play tickle here if you
want with Queen and for checking them
back but ok Queen d2 what I was gonna
say is hey is this a match where we're
gonna see hit karu have enough respect I
guess for his opponent that he's not
gonna be trolling in the opening and
playing some mainline maybe even some
home preparation with this thing Bishop
g5 well I mean what is Bishop g5 to you
it's not trolling to me but it's he
likes to go unorthodox cuz I think he
always feels that in speech a split
bullet whatever it is that he has this
innate advantage that he wants to
exploit which is is just natural comfort
level and almost anybody any position
with a speech I guess I'm saying that
because I kind of like white here right
I mean I've normally of course when
you've kind of had to extend your Center
so quickly maybe not ideal for white in
a grunt fill but in these cases I think
Queen to d2 you could even play Bishop
d2 because black can't really take a two
without queen b5 check happening so I
guess I was saying maybe it's maybe it's
something more than more than just on
Orthodox if it karo already has a clear
advantage from my perspective White has
White has a big Center majority and
these these are the types of transitions
where white is better in the god-filled
yeah we need when you get this pawn on
d5 let's say it's a general small
achievement black always has this long
term you know two-on-one on the Queen
side but it looks like here black is
sort of pressed for time to give
decassle but why it's pretty quick with
like a rook c7 type of move and even
something like Queen c4 and trading
Queens and doubling rooks he gained
control the C file I would expect white
to have a definite push in a position
like that that's exactly the white is
looking for it and of course those who
know the ground fill you have to look at
blacks potentially long-term advantage
with the two-on-one over here on the
Queen side but as a mod and I are
highlighting the the other features here
the the quick control over the only open
file the c7 square combined with kind of
the the very early extended center pawns
those are things white looks for it has
already gotten so something tells me he
Accardo feels pretty good about his
start here and the time on the clock
also suggests that vaccine maybe not
super happy with his position right
there's that bit he's going back with
the bishop to G but once he's defended
the a to pond which is what Bishop g5
looked like he was also doing as a
multi-purpose move then you start having
the news like route c4 coming with tempo
with rook c1 so maxime has retreated
Queen he's trying to guard East 7th and
c7 yeah but just based on how the game's
developing here
maxime is not necessarily in some
serious trouble but he's down a minute
and I think most people would prefer
white to the ocean I was gonna say do we
play d6 the risk of this type of move
everyone is if black can ever react with
something like a snake indeed 7 o
vaccine blunders to start the match
Hikaru
I was I was just gonna say maybe he's
gonna go with rook c8 and he had already
played it before I could even get yeah
that's that's too bad that's a that's a
bad blunder right off the bat Cara
looked like he was sort of anticipating
that that might be an easy thing to fall
into but you know okay that's that's the
first game out of the way the jitters
yeah well Maxime quickly just resigns no
point in and beating himself up Hikaru
came out a little bit of a yawn there so
he's uh he's maybe not even fully awake
yet but benefiting from a blunder but
okay I mean jokes aside from start to
finish that game though we were a little
skeptical at Bishop g5 that's about as
smooth of a win as you can get when two
players like this play so if that if
that
comes a repeated lying in the grunt
field for Maxine he may need to rethink
things a little bit that there yeah now
that's that's completely true and one
thing that has been made aware to me is
that Nakamura has actually never lost a
segment to MDL he's never lost a segment
a single segment Wow look he's going
debate the stats you can't he's brought
your five minutes yeah well I mean I
have a little angel and devil on my foot
birds whispering but that's that's
extremely impressive like to never lose
a single segment and obviously that
means he's won every match is played
against but it means that you know he
doesn't it's not like he's a bullet
player where he just collects all his
wins in the bullet segment not at all
no for sure and we know also I think
Hikaru has a lot of respect and tends to
bring his a game against Maxime
yesterday or sorry on Tuesday Hikaru was
actively in the chat while Wesley sub
was playing Gujarati and and saying he
feels like him and Max name are really a
50/50 matchup and maybe he's being a
little modest there but feels like maybe
he gives himself a slight edge if it's
bullet but somebody in the chat reminded
him Picardo you've won every single
match against Maxime so maybe slightly
more than 50/50 but he knows now a mom
brought his a-game and so did all of you
shout out to ephes our Alec TV all 2000
of you that are with us super early
thank you everyone else here and okay
more mainline stuff so what do we see
out of this system I kind of like blacks
chances when you've been managed to sort
of strand this Bishop over here on a for
now sort of a purposeless piece and here
comes c6 and b5 so what does Maxime need
to do now yeah this one started out as
we can imagine with the the Italian game
but you often see this very standard
maneuver of knight c6 to e7 and over to
g6 so basically we can fulfil the
purpose of defending the e pawn because
we don't want to take and give away at
the center but we want to do that in a
way that our night can't be harassed so
we don't want to deal with d5 we don't
wanna deal with Bishop takes c6 so we're
just rerouting it to to a much better
place where it still does the same
defensive job now this maneuver Queen b8
to a7 is actually fairly standard which
is kind of a crazy thing to say right
because it looks very weird but it's
become sort of the standard and whoa
that mr. Fisher what and she's saying
along with that look at that he's he's
saying if you play c3 I play b5 you trap
my knight wrap yours and he's saying if
c-4 that he still plays b5 loose okay so
at the end of all that pawns are falling
and who's better and he are there any
tic tacs here because otherwise I'm a
little suspicious of ya just liking
Maxine because I I wanted to take on c3
but of course I can't do that
and if I have to retreat Queen d6 so
that's another song Ollie what's the
issue here 94 we have Queen c6 which is
nice to defend right back where we just
work right that's key I think I think
that was like a he saw the the premise
of b5 was in the position but looking
back at it it didn't it didn't actually
favor him that that trade because if you
didn't take the pawn on e4 right then
white structure still looks a bit better
with the knight coming in to c4 so it
looked like Maxine probably didn't
calculate that but you know Bishop takes
a two is not something you calculate you
usually assume that it just does right
kind of an intuitive and intuitive miss
right where some sometimes you miss
tactics because there's a reason they
don't normally work and now Maxine seems
to just have the better of it he's up a
clean pawn and whether it ends up being
a passed D or past C pawns White's
playing for two results and a rare
sighting everyone take a look it's a
hick or Nakamura down on time in the
wild a rare sighting of a wild Nakamura
down on the clock
yeah no I'm not even sure if I if I
believe it here but he's he's gonna do
his best to get to get active he's not
gonna you know satisfy white by let's
say taking I think he's trying to
maintain the tension as much as he can
maybe things like rook c8 or Queen c7
and trying to play by just creating more
pressure rather than believing it
because you play move like on takes on
then the knight takes on d4 and white
starts to coordinate it a little bit I'm
in remember fat wobble asking if there's
a Photoshop competition
yet for today's match no not yet not
sure if there will be but he's really
presenting one though with those glasses
well I was gonna say we made that made
to be what we need what we need to do we
had a very obvious call to action on
Tuesday with Wesley's birthday I don't
know if you followed it but there were
some pretty hilarious Photoshop
birthdays but yeah let's do it go ahead
put a car Nakamura in the glasses
wherever you want from a fighter
what are those called in Star Wars what
are the names of those little fighter
pods where they attack Darth Vader and
the I have no I know I just pissed off
like a whole bunch of Star Wars fans you
can tell I really care if he actually
took the glasses off and he's he just
gave it face like he didn't understand
something but but more pawns seem to be
just disappearing from the positions so
I'm still trying to understand at the
very least Maxime is gonna end up one
pawn up like a clean one pawn with the
pawn on c4 is very well defended maybe
we're gonna see 95 trying to go after
that a pawn here Queen a 695 it seems
like he could potentially get that pawn
back but with the white knight jumping
in d5 or f5 and you're watching out for
huge oven this is getting pretty scary
and move like Queen c3 is very tough to
deal with because then I start really
entertaining you know sacrifices around
the King with maybe an 84 coming into
position and don't worry there's no
moves like f6 here everyone to try to
block the diagonal the g6 night would be
undefended some sort of discover check
like this so the male out now this is
the question if I can I want to play
Queen e2
almost just without thinking if I can
keep the Queen's on and I feel really
confident I can make something happen
now I'm on I mean side with you my blitz
instincts I play Queen e2 Queen g4 here
and just forget the a4 pawn and push
Heritage 5 yeah that looks pretty strong
because the move Knight d5 coming next
is gonna threaten 97 it's very tough to
deal with maybe Queen hmm maybe Queen d2
is also a move but I like I think I seem
to like Queen e2 a lot better yeah well
maxime using his time advantage wisely
here everyone that's one of the main
reasons you get up on the clock is so
you can think it through in the most
critical moment oh wow
surprised
you must really heat Alessi a game is
straightforward yeah because blacks
gonna have to spend time to take on a
four so you know he is gonna get
everything he wants he's gonna get a
pawn on age five if he wants it he's
gonna be like take that back you know he
gets to do everything but it seems to me
like the Queen's on the board was
tougher to deal with and at the very
least
Cara's moves are easy either there's
some sort of way he loses and he's not
gonna be able to stop it
yeah or he's just gonna say I'm gonna
collect some ponds and you know show me
this is I don't know - Knight checkmate
you're trying to construct the right
here the karo seems to be feeling a
little more relaxed now if the head bob
is any indication but yeah I agree with
you a hundred percent
I think Queen e2 was was frankly much
stronger and not to say that white isn't
still up a clear pawn but time is also
ticking away now for Maxime no longer
has that advantage and now he needs to
prove himself
is it the C it's a nervous feeling when
you start to give material back yeah
because you thought you had a line that
worked for you and then you start to
doubt it or you missed something and
then you're like okay wait a minute
I you know I can't just keep giving
giving pawns back careful you're a car
trying to trade f7 for c4 with this last
move saying you can you can take but
when I went in the house probably a
knight on e6
yeah is looking really like a nice
defensive piece there right c4 is always
gonna be hanging like you said if white
takes on f7 I mean white still
dominating here but maybe some maneuver
like knight c6 to e5 trying to put more
pressure on f7 and also guard c4 to fold
I like this idea and so did Maxime he
plays nice e6 well can't look back and
regret the Queen trade at this point
next he just has to focus ahead but I
think what you said there is really true
I wonder if he had some sort of concrete
line he had calculated that turned out
not to work right yeah and now now he's
left trying to prove his his lone pawn
yeah maybe maybe we see Brooke f8 here
I'm not sure like if you were given this
position just I still feel like I should
be trying to play things like rugby -
and rook a to and shoes activity is the
best defense if I can write so
if you play Brooke b2 here let's say
right I guess what what I'm wondering is
how do you deal with like let's say
Brooke on f5 or or something like that
right Brooke on f1 rook on f5 it's like
you commit everything down there and
then white you know it takes one move
out of his day to play defensive move
and you get a little scared but that's
nakamura style he's going for rugby too
I think this is probably objectively not
the best move but we'll see how NVL
handles it yeah one issue that White's
facing here is everything about his only
advantage which was this extra c-pawn
has been completely blockaded you almost
want moves like like ninety eight to
work or oh wow okay no he he decides I'm
not gonna try to prove that advantage
anymore and just just simplify but I'm
feeling more and more like stars are
gonna hold the draw here is he going for
some sort of like convoluted mate it
seems like he wants to stick that knight
on c6 I don't know he seems to be going
for something here but rook got four
looks like a very nice move because
Brooke f5 looks a bit annoying up just
the policemen of the Brooke on the F
file feels very good very secure but
there's only 17 seconds for a car here
so white white is is much better but
haptics rook takes she cheats nice work
it's everything back no well he's gonna
start okay yeah I was gonna say gonna
start getting worried about getting wait
oh hey Cara looks off to the side and
realizes at the end of that line he
blundered laughing it off he was one one
move like one move ahead of himself
let's say one tempo tempo away from
having successfully defended a worse
position very well and then just gave it
away I don't know if you had to take
that night on g6 that seemed a little
rash like I think he did it because he
just thought that's an easy
simplification for equality right but
this Brooke II five shot was the only
way cuz if white doesn't win a piece
there you play Knight f6 then white
doesn't win that position so maybe he
played too fast there because I'm not
sure that that was forced by any means
well interesting well two decisive games
to start the match here but maybe not in
the fashion we all expected some some
blunders by both players but that's
what's in Bullitt now we see a
Pete Hikaru's Bishop to g5 from Game one
for those of you just joining us he's
gonna say hey man you show me why it's
not winning I'm gonna keep playing it
so now maxime switching it up here for
those of you as we said just joining us
the actually hikaru switched it up first
right Bishop e3 is different than
Hikaru's game one move which was which
was the move Knight to e2 so so far
we're seeing a bit of a Zaman set a
challenge if if you're not gonna beat me
I'm gonna keep going back to that well
yeah I underwent felt structures that
when white achieves sort of the past
bond here when black plays e5 if I could
play 92 let's say and you have to let's
say you take me and I play Bishop takes
to me I think white is doing very well
in those in those positions nice easy
easy advantage so of course you never
play the green felt like that you don't
just take deny trade because then white
just has this past funny as the C file
what's not to like about the position
instead he wants to say you know I'm
gonna give you this pawn on d4 and I'm
gonna respond with probably very active
moves like f5 Ruki a very quick play
there's also Queen i5 that he's probably
gonna throw in at some point so for
example here Queen a5 yes yeah you have
to you have to move the King because
because of the loose piece on d4 and
after Queen a to rook C to queen a6 he
might go for a job King neft read King
III I'm liking it looks like he's
probably gonna do that King walk
learning something from Sam Shanklin as
US teammate that uh English can walk
safely in the middle of the board yes he
might he might also be very close to
winning king of the hill and winning a
game at the same time so if he managed
to do both and maybe she says no right
sort of side like prop bet going you
know so we're not that we're not aware
of what does he need to is definitely I
mean
you have to play right but it still
throws Maxine off because it's just such
a weird move to deal with yep okay well
so like if King f3 strange as it is you
can actually play Bishop g4 which is key
I was gonna say that might be I might be
walking the King just a tad too far nice
little thing work tactic to show though
the fans but the problem is that you're
if you don't play king of three the move
f3 is is it met by Queen takes d5
because this e4 pawn is pinned yes
although I'm not sure that white would
be terribly upset with the resulting
endgame but I guess I suppose neither
could black you can't give say with that
so a free Queen d5 might actually just
lead to a pretty serious equality after
Bishop d7 and mass mass trades I'm
wondering if there's a more active with
wait should be for I think I don't think
I'm missing something Bishop g4 maybe
okay yes this is the one you talked
about and the King has one each three
but this is not good yeah this is this
is very good for black my guess is that
he he must have missed this tactic but I
just want to make sure that maybe I
wasn't missing something with f3 because
if maybe there was a tactic even worse
with that through it then you had to go
for this but somehow I feel it that was
it would just be surprising to believe
that at karo misses usually he's the one
who coming up with those tricks
consistently and blitzen bullets so yeah
now this is a very very bad game Queens
are still on the board
another pawns falling so it's two pawns
plus opposite bishops very good when
you're attacking and the king is coming
on h3 what's yeah not sure not sure what
was happening perhaps he took his profit
a little too seriously with the king of
the hill idea but okay this would be a
very interesting change in momentum
right Hikaru gets off to a quick kind of
easy win in this exact line in the
grünfeld blunders away the last game it
looks like he might lose this one too so
if you and I were for to assess how
what's the recipe maxing bhashya The
Grove
finally overcomes his his sort of demons
here and beat Sakura Nakamura
I would have to say that he has to have
a lead headed into Bullitt whether
that's even just a 1 or a 2 game lead
earned over the 5 and 3-minute portions
but he has to be better going into the
bold portion or he has no chance what do
you think yeah that makes a lot of sense
in terms of the the decision he has to
make right now I guess it's it's he
knows that having the Queens on the
board is it is the better option but
let's save rook takes d5 Bishop c4 and
if we reach 5 you can take that with the
Queen and it gets it gets unnecessarily
messy so yeah I think he wants to play
me like rook d5 but then if Queen d5 the
other way you have the two pawns but the
King on h3 is not a problem once the
Queens are off the board but it's
opposite bishops you might start it to
just have these hallucinations as black
like oh maybe this is not best I mean it
only has to be something with those two
pastors but I was gonna say the other
option is to just go all-in
I love this move g5 force and she
doesn't want yeah
h5 now looks pretty strong with g4
coming or H takes G must be verb t1
maybe I love this move h5 I don't think
there's any moves you gotta play G want
anything to keep anything more coming
there the threat now in our uptakes f2
is is over cards actually a fun move
though is f5 f5 would be a fun move to
play depends where white puts the Queen
here but that it seemed like he spent
the time there and really found the most
correct and direct approach because I
can tell you if I traded Queens there
with Nakamura I probably lose the
position of two connected passed pawns
Wow nice nice very nice game g5 and h5
was just too accurate when someone plays
that that well in a position like that
where you need to make a critical
decision when you have a big advantage
yeah you just found the absolute best
wait wait so I'm surprised that Hikaru
changed up the move order in that
obscure Grunfeld maybe he goes away from
it completely now I'm on but hey Cara
changed up the move order and was just
never never close to the kind of session
had in Game one and suddenly Maxime has
has one hour has won the first two games
in a row mini winning streak here and a
car has to stop the bleeding
yep and he's gone for the on here
which is normally a stop the bleeding
opening right very solid reputation as
as most people are familiar with but the
way that the advance Carrick on actually
gets played is not actually necessarily
that safe black actually usually goes
for some kingside expansion with the
pawns and whites 91 usually facilitates
me looks like Bishop to h5 f4 Knight to
d3 all these kind of ideas so it's
actually not some sort of dry open
Kerouac on that that we might use to be
seen right yeah definitely the kind of
hero con where both sides can play for a
win but still why did it wait a little
bit better
yeah maybe three has been played here
you don't have to do anything with this
tension I mean you can play Queen b6 you
can play rook c8 c4 I can say is
probably not what I was expecting
yeah that's good yeah you sort of want
white to you sort of want black to or
leave the normal pressure on the darks
were launching and ducing this move yeah
yeah not not that it's a bad move but
it's for better or for worse it's what
white wants to achieve right no pressure
on d4 so he's now sure is white gonna be
really aggressive but things like be
three and a four just try to completely
open up or do you do are you happy that
you've relieved the pressure on the
center here and then go back to your
your normal area of assault on the
kingside here look for things like f4
try to just open up an attack on the
kingside this should page 5 also find
yeah they should be tried with that for
honestly you start looking at lines like
that and white may have a loss what's a
lot gonna do them a be sure black might
play d5 96 maybe even try to castle long
but I'm under the impression that Bishop
h5 an f4 comes very quickly with maybe a
knight going to e3 you know and one
thing you have to be careful of as black
and in some of these positions is how
easily your structure can be sacrificed
against right for example Bishop h5 put
a knight on e3 and all of a sudden you
have ideas like
takes d5 in e6 just just as like a
tactical idea you can really expose this
this structure or this the center really
really well
Bishop III you might even consider sac
in the exchange
yeah I'm even close to like a gnat for
move yes something like that
anything it might be unnecessary but
okay yeah it makes team decides it is
but but I love your point in fact I
really like 93 now with that immediate
threat you highlighted maybe I'm taking
d5 and punching e6 through right yeah 93
looks like a good one
b3 looks totally reasonable because we
can just take on c4 do the same plan and
it also involves Queen i-4 just as an
extra threat so we can still follow up
with Knight to e3 f4 is a little more
off the cards now that that Bishop d3
has been played but I don't think I'm
wrong in saying that that white is
probably better here quickly clicked on
the link that yes may share in the
twitch chat of a gif of a car was hair
blowing in the wind so sorry got a
little distracted there thank you to
everybody who's having fun
staying involved in another chat whether
you're a chess TV or twitch TV / yes yes
yeah I can see on the cameras
his hair is blowing but normally in the
Old Spice you know commercials where
where you see this this sort of stuff
yeah I think that usually the guy who
has his hair blowing the wind is he's a
lot more confident than a car probably
is right now yeah so he's got it he's
got a reclaim the lead you gonna say but
you got these two bishops here dark
squares this is a you're about to see
this in some sort of this is where you
play like Queen take c6 or yeah you know
there's some sort of puzzle book made
here even Bishop takes f7 s on your mind
yeah absolutely
okay I had a mission is defended on a3
so if you wanted to play a move like
Queen f3 here sort of Intermezzo to hit
f7 I'm looking at that move what do you
think the issue is you don't really want
to leave the knight on c2 undefended I
think he's gonna respond with rook aged
7 to that move okay weird as it is but
there are a few things hanging like
the c29 like the a3 bishop but maybe
that that's that's good Queen f3 rook h7
follow up with Bishop takes Bishop and
then 93 for example and then play Knight
g4 into f6 or we have these Knight takes
d5 very very serious threats with a six
coming yeah so 93 yeah this looks really
convincing karma quickly plays rook c8
okay Danny look 995 is a tile and I'm
looking at it on the analysis board just
for you the knight can come to f6 at the
end of the line and white has Bishop
takes f7 so it's it's not an upload but
let's just well it's very close but not
quite uh I want to play Ethan check
after Neffs yeah okay see if you seven
check Tate's but then Queen takes f6 and
I'm just not sure about that position
right something like ninety eight let's
say right or even ninety six right white
white ken kaneki I'm running out of
Tillery yeah you don't want the night to
come to g6 and maybe then f4 and naca
played rook c8 because he he was
concerned about the more obvious move I
take c4 so that's why I played rook c8
well by the finest it's it's on the
board I mean it's too tempting rabbits
yelling this for the last ten moves I'm
sure it's been on his mind so what does
he have in store look we have to assume
that it gets taken otherwise blacks out
of the game well hey carros gonna
calculate now he quickly played rooks a
gauge for the reason you think t5 he
wants night do you take c5 is like a
bailout he's going for it
okay cuz the other option is Bishop
takes f7 year but that looks like you're
running out of a lot of stuff Queen d7
and King g7
yeah I'm I'm kind of confident that
black is gonna defend here and so I'm
you know in the line that we highlighted
with e7 Knight takes Queen takes f6 and
then 96 okay so he Hikaru now has to
figure out how to deal with this f7 pawn
but can't you even take f7 and and get
the two miners for the rook yes you
definitely can I'm wondering what
happens after that okay he's gone for it
yeah I play analysis looks pretty
straightforward to me
I think the bishop cover
b1 is actually really important
preventing white from getting any more
active pieces involved in the attack
everyone that's a great point and and I
think that the evaluation here has
completely shifted I mean black has to
be happy at least from the perspective
you were just worse in a middle game
worried about these tactics well the
tactics came and went and and now you're
just fine white needs something right
here this is the moment because you've
got the rooks doubled on the e-file I
mean I can see a few threats but yes you
need an h4 you need this night in the
game because otherwise black will
consolidate you time for Brooke f8
already I stick a knight on e4 for
example and running out of so maybe it's
a B I play g4 then keep it closed backup
the bishop from d3 and g6 and start
feeling kinda like hibernating for the
winter very comfy right there on the
Kings side yeah he's gone for this
exchange I'm assuming that he's gonna go
for it with some sort of H take two GE
and Knight
you know into F three and five but I
think he card did a pretty good job
defusing the situation and in hindsight
maybe that Knight takes e5 I was a
little hasty by an overconfident and be
out he knew his position was good but
where he was just feeling our vibe you
know we were we were sent into the
positive Knight takes d5 and he the
commentators curse I was feeling it I
mean I had to deliver that that to the
chat yes I knew that MDL would play it
if I lobbied for it hard enough no well
now Maxime is down a minute and a half
on the clock and suddenly you start to
wonder where this game has gone a
rhetorical question was asked by our
stat guy behind the scenes whether
Hikaru has ever trailed as he currently
does to one like ever in any speech
Chess Championship match besides his
matches to Magnus and I think the answer
is yes I remember his match with Fabio
Caruana where he actually lost at least
the first game and may have even been
down two games in that match so I can
answer that one from memory Hikaru has
trailed before I think a better question
would be has an outcome or ever trailed
sort of later on into the match right
because it's very easy for someone to to
have a stat broken by you
losing the first game list right now
okay I never am from that perspective
you may be right I I don't remember a
carro ever heading into the bullet
portion of a match again besides against
Magnus Carlsen not leading the match
right that that's a that's a for sure
yeah now I think it's pretty safe to say
this does not look good for NDL Brooklyn
h4 is sort of offside and an obvious
reason tonight's going to go to f3 but I
mean basically if if we put our king on
f6 king g5 is never an issue because of
Knight f3 but I was gonna say if we just
trade pieces King f6 or something we
just trade pieces I think that that
blacks was better in the end game well
this move Knight f6 was a really nice
way to to force this Pony back the
threat of heading into e4 and hitting
the c3 pawn okay now he goes for your
original idea what the king improving
itself to f6 but the main thing White
has to watch out for here is is hey karo
getting a night where it can target the
c3 pawn now he can play Knight f6 if he
wants but the knight on c6 is staying
there to guard Knight to e5 but as soon
as that's off the table you're gonna see
that night reroute maybe to like d5 or
somewhere where it can operate who's
guarding b1 with this move that's that's
King f6 guarding it's a super nice fine
and you forced out of that earlier in
this game of on the bishop preventing
the rook from ever getting involved on
the Queen side that's got nearly
dominates the position oh wow I've
seemed willing to simplify I'm not sure
that is CP g5 well I mean the knight can
go would be 97 and e6 although I'm not
sure about that I felt like he had just
kind of found a way to play tickle and
hold and and now he's transitioned I'm
liking him Carlos chances better here
yeah the night's gonna relocate itself
perhaps to e6 goblet for that pawn I
think that this works out for black
because gem for happens so quickly now
just deep dive you can't take a four or
you can't he does well he has evened up
the rook to prevent the c3 pawn but I
don't think he can hold this
a good try because the king goes to III
I'd say it's a good I'd say it's almost
his only try but we're gonna see D for
here and King before and the thing has
to go sit on c1 and the question is do
you clean up these pawns on it I'm
pretty sure you answers yes I think you
have to take a four first and hope you
can get back in time and he does so here
comes the G pawns yeah the King the king
is too fast I think yeah I've seen that
was whatever calculation is necessary to
quickly recognized that he has to throw
in the towel and that was a nice a nice
conversion because the things got a
little messy when both players were low
on time he's immediately repeated this
he's already got something in mind as he
fires off this Bishop g5 line which yeah
to me this is like preparations for the
match that's what it looks starting to
feel that way right I mean Hikaru
you know he's known for mixing it up and
as we said in the game one right playing
obscure opening so this is the first
time I've ever seen him really be as
stubborn as he is here sticking to his
guns and a line that kind of feels he
likes for white well you have to I mean
speaking of stubborn you have to point
your finger at the other guy in this
match who is very stubborn with his
opening right he naca I mean probably
knows that he's facing a stubborn
opponent who is going to repeat his
opening lines so if he plays e4 he knows
he's getting that that Sicilian I don't
just I was just about to highlight yeah
I mean you're not going in 44 and let's
make a face tonight or if any way so he
might as well stick to his guns with d4
if you're Hikaru right so he knew that
the grünfeld was coming as soon as he
signed up for this
d4 and so he probably just prepared this
sort of offbeat line where he was
confident he would be more familiar with
things since it's relatively unusual
right maybe six threatens discovered
checks we have an undefended Bishop on
e3 but I takes f3 did not work there
everyone because of the move he gave to
rook takes f3 right or brooke takes a
three duh well King f2 then I might go
back to well not was before he was
hanging but yeah oh yeah
so the question for me is deed take this
night with your night and then move your
bishop how's that structured Knight
takes Knight pawn takes sure bishop f2
or Bishop f4 and just try to leave your
Bishop on d3 and and consider it the
gatekeeper against this week d4 pawn
right so you follow up with Queen e2 or
Queen d3 fell by Brooke c1 and it seems
as though blacks like blacks main plan
when I say it's bishop on d3 seems to
revolve around either putting a rock on
c8 and then dropping in on c4 and saying
you can't take me or that you know I'm
gonna have some ponds that roll or I
have to play a 5 B 4 and Bishop e5 and
get this Bishop out of the way I'm not
sure he can do that yeah it feels like
White has has done what he's needed to
do initially but can i play Queen d2 and
rook up to c1 coordinating quickly to
the Queen side before before black
definitely definitely want one thing I
was considering I think that if black
doesn't open himself up to his sacrifice
here he might get in trouble something I
like is maybe Queen e2 something like B
for rook c1 Queen b6 and if I could just
get like rook c8 rook c3 I just want
some sort of rook on the C file whether
it's on c4 c3 and the bishops are so
strong together but as soon as you give
me one of them and I start to
potentially connect my three funds
because let's not forget I do kind of
have three ponds that I've snuck past
the halfway mark there and if I can
somehow connect my D pawn with my other
two pawns I think that could be pretty
good compensation I like it
Wien goes to c1 though instead hikaru
likes the idea perhaps of ooh I was
gonna say putting her on b2 to prepare
this and he just takes immediately he
just takes it yeah Queen B - I guess
before was what's happening he goes
straight for it and after Bishop takes
me five I guess first 43 I'm just gonna
say a four it probably is the idea right
you don't want to play Queen B - because
of d3 check right a four late - to win
back the material and it looks like it's
gonna happen
cleanly yes there are a few things to
consider I mean that feels like there's
a lot of likes or in between moves with
Brooks Yates on the horizon and that
this DP check so it feels like a loose
tactic if I can say that like you I'm
not sure that everything's been fully
accounted for but it just he's trusting
his intuition anticipate he'll put the
Queen on a3 after a move like rook c8
right right but then Bishop Fe with a
queen a to I guess I'm still kind of you
may have or Queen b3 we can do okay but
the card does manage to win back that
piece on b5 without any further damage
upon his opponent as your as your buddy
yes or would have said yeah so Queen e1
makes this is fun we've got a couple of
passers push a baby yeah yes beep on is
about to do some lethal damage with b7
but once you stop it
the long-term pressure of the bishop
controlling a1 is actually more
concerning thing it's a very key point
this a for pawn is or dangerous in the
long run because of the help of the
other pieces here but okay now there's
moves like Bishop a5 and Bishop e3 if
I'm desperate to hold on to b6 right
okay you go yes it should be free looks
more natural got to get that Queen out
of there so I ran her to a5 if I can
okay he goes yeah b7 immediately but
look out for ideas like Queen a5 or even
if you tau he was a follow up I think
with the Queen a5 and you know you take
my beep on I get Queen d8 and Bishop h6
check I was gonna say even Queen eight
wins the rook and some lines but that
that's even better so if the Queen comes
to 85 now why can't take on b7 for
either one of our our flavors we like
Queen d8 or Queen a8 I mean Bishop f4 is
in the position and so is rook C one
who's gonna sayin this is this is maybe
even more simpler than either one of us
anticipated Bishop c3 I should think is
met by a queen g3 or or do you just I
think you can even just play Bishop d2
and if you take it you take back and the
rook is still hanging yeah 52 Bishop c3
in blacks got a lot of problems but
Bishop d2 maybe just Queen D or B 4
is what he's yeah okay she yeah I
thought maybe he would try to give the
peace but he's gonna find some tricky
way to keep lying here Thanks everything
in what and then what is just not enough
I mean this is the deep pocket he
resigns hikaru after losing two in a row
I wonder how often that's happened
speaking of questions and things that
have happened to karo and matches that
weren't against Magnus that should be
like a book yes that that there's a lot
of stats in that book we could probably
also write a book with all the different
outfits Accardo known for bringing his
personality to the chess board for all
3,500 view that missed it you showed up
today wearing glasses yellow glasses and
we have our Photoshop competition one
year diamond membership we have a gift
there from our own chess comm staff
member are in Hawaii give us give us a
hick our Nakamura wearing those sweet
glasses from earlier in the match or you
know what or do a gif of his hair
blowing in the wind along with other
supermodels either one of those is
acceptable I think the winner is the
person who can incorporate both of them
yep there you go if you can somehow you
have the challenge from a mont hamilton
himself and who's no stranger to
photoshop contests no well actually I'd
look like a photo I'm basically are
walking Photoshop contest and let's all
right now a lot of fun we're so here
what do you have there right MBL you
were that you were the recipient of a
couple of nakamura rare blunders now you
got to stop the bleeding and and both
sides as you said being stubborn we're
back to that opening where her car will
grab the a2 pawn but Maxime says not
this time it just puts the bishop on b3
yeah he wasn't he wasn't having it I can
see that rooks still stationed on a1
it's got a full time job watching over
that pawn now that he knows that not
cameras man enough to take it yep so
he's watching over that this is a much
more to me but we liked his chances
there I mean that was not a I'm not a
pawn we we applauded Takara for taking
send the montage to Twitter it barracks
asking to use the hashtag speed chess on
Twitter with any of your Photoshop
entries into our one-year Diamond
membership contest alright but these
positions feel very comfortable for
black now that he hasn't tried to take
the a pawn like a thief
yeah this very equal definitely come
comfortable the night on f8 needs some
redistribution on the board because from
g6 you saw Maxine immediately do what
everybody needs to needs to know against
the net on g6 the quick g3 h4 really
deals with that night effectively and
you know after King g2 here I mean white
is definitely preferred I would say got
that a5 on a target I got this this upon
but it's really tricky once you you say
okay maybe be six maybe I just bring the
rook to e7 and rook e8 and it's like
okay I have targets what do you have
yeah I have the e4 pawn to b3 pawn right
I meaning neither one of us a car Oh
plenty black pieces yes and yeah our
stock I appoint sout again we've had
five games no draws so if you like
watching hard-fought chess it seems to
be a theme of this year's feat chess
championship Amman we've had so many
matches where and if you watch much of
the Deuter Grichuk epic match but I
watched as much as I could very excited
we had a 12 or 13 game run there with
not a single draw really a lot of fun
this is good we have you guys are
championing to no draw and then we we
have tournaments like Norway chess who
are trying to follow suit yeah
interesting article today right what did
you think about that we've actually had
comments already people asking at
Armageddon only time controls as a
variant on chess calm make a memory yet
in a more regular part of the speed
chess championship so well I think this
is the first time we really get to see
it I mean we've seen it utilize of
course in competition round not nor
himself as as played number of
Armageddon match like whether it's like
decider and US Championship whether it's
a World Cup or something but this is the
first sort of classical exposure where
you really get to see a lot of it and if
it works or if it doesn't is I think
it's gonna be very parent from this
tournament so this is kind of like the
the test run and everyone's gonna be
paying very close attention but I think
that the change is very welcomes
I'd definitely be interested in hearing
what these guys think after the match
about Thursday that format yeah we're
certainly gonna ask them and for those
of you wondering what in the world are
Danny in a Mon talking about these crazy
guys I'm gonna go ahead and share a link
with you and both the chest comm TV chat
and the twitch TV last just yet so some
brand new chain brand-new is no
increment and although I count all these
no drawers and say we haven't had a
peaceful one yet this okay don't want to
speak too soon I like acardo's chances
here with this past sea pond but this
may be the closest we have had to a
peaceful result of any game yet right
Brook c6 doesn't look like it does the
trick because I think maybe I could take
it so Brook c6 takes takes in a Ford c7
maybe Queen a 5 and I have Queen 88 if
you grab my I'm just bust out a vintage
Accardo take stakes there were two
captures I'm used to a car and dealing
with actors performs as team you did it
you did it
Brooke rook takes rook to c6 takes takes
takes takes mate all right no but the C
pawn is running so Brooke c6 is a move
that makes sense regardless of the jokes
you don't want black to get enough power
behind it that it can't be stopped so um
and BL probably calculating along the
lines of what am on just set can I
afford to take d6 or do I need to try to
put the kibosh on the C pawn now yeah I
think he probably has to deal with it
because rook c6 if it's captured then
Queen b6 looks like a more effective way
to to just corral that guy you know so
yeah he probably has to go for it this
allowing this fun to get all the way
down the board is is very dangerous one
of the key lines everyone is if takes
takes c2 White has this move rook to c3
I think is there Brooke take c4 rook to
c3 might be what he wants to play I mean
of course is what he wants to play but
that looks like a very sketchy arrange
yeah the were coming to e4 looks like it
would overwhelm the Queen so where's
well a car was gonna calculate and if he
takes takes and plays c2 I don't see
anything
rooks III for example rooks III rookie
for Queenie for Queen takes c3 Queen e8
are we getting a draw I think we are how
aunt mediate on Queen right mg6
oh that's true I'm showing it on the
analysis board but I was looking at line
it and that was my worry as I wonder if
Maxine yeah no you're right and my C
pawn is not as impressive as the one on
c2 right and it's always really bad when
your pawn is cleaning on the same file
as your opponent's but your one move
behind because the Queen controls CA for
us and I'm wondering if the I think the
trick on rook takes e4 was the move
Queen to d2 I think that was maxim's
plan and now all the sudden there is a
threat of c7 so the karma comes up with
a different approach maybe Maxime did
calculate accurately enough to hold
let's go back to that line Queenie one
rook takes e4 showing on the analysis
board that I think Queen d2 might have
been the idea and maybe maybe what are
we gonna get that potential again like
does he have to play yeah we may have a
repeat you might play Brooke c4 instead
rook c4 then rook takes e4 yeah maybe
maybe rook c4 rook takes e4 the Queen e1
rookie for Queen d2 was was the line
that yeah that we couldn't deal with
that seemed kind of looking a little
stressed out there as I go back for this
line does he have King f1 I mean take c1
King takes rookie for king d2 obviously
well we're not gonna find out what the
problem is probably rook takes d4 after
king of Wands ah immediately very nice
okay yeah good point
so that's speaking of all that you know
shebang about drawers there's one
there's one no I was just gonna say we
did again the commentators curse
continues we talk about five games
without a peaceful result well Game six
was the was destiny destiny for the
first peaceful result we're back to this
Grunfeld and Hikaru liking his chances
it will be C Queen b6 again nope
no he's fed up with that I mean I'm
impressed that Hikaru hasn't repeated
his first win
because it's like hey what was what was
wrong with that life yeah what was wrong
with 92 and and on the analysis board
for all of you just joining us the first
game of the match was this exact
position but Hikaru chose the line with
92 and one of the key differences in
this move order is the black does not
have e53 supporting the Knights position
for obvious reasons here there's a
there's a hold on to your lady's right
so so because of that we saw Bishop g4
and then Queen to d2 and a game where he
caught one very cleanly so Ahmad and I
as we're saying now that that's exactly
what we're highlighting Hikaru has not
gone back to that for some reason and
has at once since at least not in this
line yep
and you really can't blame naka for
continuing to play this line because I
mean hey it's working Yellin and he
clearly came in with that intention
maybe this is just a five-minute thing
to play this line right in the
five-minute portion but it's working
really well I see the the stats are
almost aligning for naca winning against
MVL 5-4 in the five-minute portion right
it has always been their score even a
five-minute portion really we'll see if
we'll see if that book and you're just
you you brought your A game along with
although we you know it's really nice
when you're on camera and you can just
look at a prompter this is it looks so
good oh this martyr just that's actually
had a carro at least this year being
favored six to three maybe that was what
he won last year and but but no you're
right I mean that is that we're right on
line with a card of winning one time
control after another way that he
normally does so thank you for the bits
donated already ten bucks more into the
$3,000 price when these two guys are
playing for today so we appreciate all
the support from all of you and it goes
directly in their pockets and yeah all
right I think there was a I think there
was a lion
so instead of rook d1 because right now
we're just down upon as as Hikaru if
white plays rook takes c3 pawn takes c3
Queen takes c3 I was wondering what
what's going on with rook c8 like this
bishop on d3 maybe is a little bit loose
or of course the pawn on a two could
be potentially taken but rook c8 looked
like the annoying move he didn't take it
I guess Queen D for their queen D for
the d7 is hanging at the you know if the
black tries to gobble the e to pawn with
the penis
yeah it's just weird that he he clearly
played this 'if i move to disconnect a
bishop from the pond so I thought that
rook rook takes would be to follow up
but I think that he's saying or he was
trying to say that maybe either he
messed up or he wanted to collect that
deep on later but and I seen as a very
clear manager yeah I'm not sure either I
tried to use the analysis board to
highlight your analysis but hey because
he's got the he's got the extra pawn now
into is hanging the bishops from blacks
perspective are working perfectly and
this h4 move can just be completely
ignored you know and this is the design
of you know involving Harry for bogus
magic right this is like your where's
the attack on the King site here this is
more like a Simon William special there
yeah okay Bishop c5 c5 looks natural and
good no issues there b5 is defended you
can drop that guy back to b6 Bishop e6
maybe try to trade a to for b5 how many
times repeat this line if he continues
to not get the success he had in Game
one question is this is this feels like
it's it's all mvl here
nice move if he wants to play d3 here
yeah thought I like it I think it was
totally worth giving up that pawn now
okay there was a threat of Bishop takes
up two with the bishop hanging right so
if you take on f2 though it's gotta be I
was thinking in my fault with something
like Bishop a4 in some positions gang up
on g2 and if g3 is played
who knows maybe I it real frisky on the
light squares right it's always annoying
though when you have two bishop in front
of your queen and you just wish you
could flip around flip the battery
around
or made so I mean Queen D for it looks
like he can't play Queen III because of
Queen B - right well he - that that
looks wrong
so queen or king g3 and maybe clear
advantage for it for black but you still
have some work to do right where's the
where's the beef plays Queen d4 and ooh
or Oh says I Molly this okay Queen B -
what's going on after D - it's gonna
meet this has to be baby - I'm guessing
and then probably Bishop g4 right that
this looks I think it's us just waiting
great I think it's winning because
that's also Bishop e2 don't forget I
just like Queen C Wineman they're a rosy
line though Bishop c4 I take and play e6
let you get a clean and then I get e
seven and there's actually no checks
okay I was just looking at that um well
he's gone for my second recommendation
which seems to be a lot better because
d1 threatens the Queen right Queen e1
threatens to Queen and brass
yeah and now after the Queen e1 check I
think we will get Bishop she foreign and
just like it's gonna be a queen okay
it's gonna be a queen in a shack but
always grab a pawn if you can yeah now
Bishop to Bishop g4 you could play King
g7 right or King h7 beside he doesn't
need to if he was worried about your
check I thought that hey the Queen will
come to f6 but there's no professional
very common maneuver where the King
finds itself on h7 after Queen d8 and e6
is covered for any sickly and things
like this bill to fish would be sick so
that's a good little I mean a small
educational takeaway for all those of
you with us recognizing that there is no
perpetual and those types of those types
of bets because you have both h7 and g7
so a good thing to just quickly
recognize and know right and MBL quickly
ties up the match here am on I uh I
don't know I'm feeling I'm feelin am I
feeling could you tell what am I feeling
can you help me understand what are you
feeling buddy what am I feeling here I
feel with the hundred bits there from
books are nice
that's that's a good feeling but what am
I feeling here I'm feeling this is a
gonna be a very you know if Maxine that
we've seen against yeah you know as
again a lot of the pregame talk was
about the fact that this is a the most
hotly anticipated matchup before the
semi finals to be honest and I I
personally believe that whoever wins
this match today goes on to win the
entire speech s championship this year
right so the winner goes on to face is
Romeo smart yeah well thanks Aronian in
the semies but I think it's fair to say
that either MDL or her car will be
favored throughout the rest of the
format so anyway interesting stuff by
litte bit of a close match thanks to all
4000 of you that are here we're and
again we're seeing a much more stubborn
approach from both players than I
anticipated I anticipated he carro being
is b3 g3 let me push Harry the aged upon
self I'm on but he's not he's going back
to the same openings that he feels like
he was gonna get against Maxine and I
think he's gonna loosen up as the time
controls shorten but he clearly came in
with a plan so if anyone in the chat
happens to be an expert at the c53 Joko
piano game main line Joko piano if any
small variation you guys are in for a
treat yeah because you're getting like a
master class on it today liquid egg
product books are nice again string dog
you got thank you everyone you are
making and making these players very
happy and and and having some fun with
them before the match started I told
them that if either of them sacked the
Queen I would do like a call to action
for some sort of on donation but they
haven't sacked the Queen yet these guys
are just being being really good chess
players on one what's the deal with that
yeah it's some in some ways it's more
fun to watch mistakes happen we already
had Team Canada at the loop yet right I
guess that's true so I had enough yeah
well we're glad to have you back I know
you and Eric both talk this week it
wasn't your favorite performance but the
chess bras will be back in action and
full coverage of the World Chess
Championship at twitch.tv slash just raw
so yeah we feel we feel safer
not making the moves just commentating
on we're more at home there all right
well here hey karo has gotten his best
positioned yet on the black side of this
he's in balance that's that's already a
start and no matter what there's gonna
be this Queen side versus central
majority here he's gonna be able to
swing that rope over to AAA and it
doesn't look particularly dangerous for
for white yet because both players are
capable of you know just flinging those
rooks over the a file I'm probably a
little more concern for for black if I
just had to pick because and this may be
why you feel the a pawn it's just more
vulnerable than I did this year the e
pawn yeah I I don't necessarily even
believe myself when I say it I think
it's very close to equal but it seems
like with two rooks on the board and the
white king maybe being able to enter the
action a little quicker can you have
three III d3 that maybe it'll be a draw
but it doesn't look like white is in any
danger with you know we've seen some
dangerous dangerous past pawns and this
match so far this doesn't feel like it's
one of them yet yeah so you have to take
that night if you want to get your
Brooke a8 moving yeah he's yeah
basically what what is expecting that
pawn is not dangerous and so they're
just like the other side interested in
playing now one out we have a deadlock
at four here with about thirty minutes
left and another okay ninety to know
somebody somebody analyze Game one
deeply for us real quick and tell us
what you think it is he's not liking
about ninety two because he well he
might do that in the break or so III
mean I we won't I don't have time during
the break but I'm curious if we if we
get a little bit of analysis because it
seems like he's not getting the
advantage he did early on and unless
there's some sort of match strategy to
go back to it when the when the gloves
start coming off and the faster time
controls I don't know
so but you and I are getting a grünfeld
lesson whether we signed up for it or
not or Mon again two-on-one on the Queen
side will white be able to
of corral and strangle out this D pawn
and use the central pawn majority before
black really gets Queen side pressure
that's my quick sort of philosophical
we've now seen this position five times
everybody and that's a battle right
black has to be quick white wants to
control the only open file and like we
said hopefully get real pressure here or
mobilize his pawns before black gets
gets too far away on the Queen so maybe
we're gonna see my rook to c3 finally
the exchange sacs that a mont called for
many months ago now it's it's still i
liked i highlighted queen of three among
precisely because i just don't like the
queen on the file this rook and quickly
maxine plays rook d8 with the idea that
Bishop takes b5 is not possible because
of d3 check right and I feel like the
Queen is Ronnie - I feel like he should
hey Cora should have played the move I
said with Queen f3 because it also
active or not favoring white yeah and
consistently in this light right he
keeps going back to it and yeah I didn't
mind the the line it seems like though
as soon as you start to play f4 things
really loosen up and I'm not sure that's
necessarily in white's favor because
there's all sorts of sacrifices on the C
file this d3 check in every line the f5
move or taking or d5 with the pin on the
e-file and just loosening up the entire
chain with f4 yeah last time you did
that he had to commit to e5 pretty much
the next room right and they drop the D
pawn so yeah it doesn't I'm not
convinced by this so far I don't mind
the line in general but I I feel I feel
vindicated one time in my life right
versus a car oh there's no way you play
Queen e2 and then Queen a through the
next move without egg no D though the
rook the rook is worse on da as you
really think so is much worse than no
good so I'm not going to hated thanks
I'm on of course not Danny +1 for you
but ok here comes the pawn to f5 and and
now you know in all seriousness this
does seem like the everything for what
to do but I think we're gonna see your
rooks III idea oh it's in it's in the
physician is thinking that it's
happening but without the I'll say with
with the bishops off the board it's less
convincing although just king net1 move
is
we to deal with Brooks III I think
because soon as you you play rogue c3 if
I take and you take with the beep on
those two pawns don't scare me with a
nice blockade on d3 yeah and if you take
with the deep on I mean d6 is already on
the board yeah yeah a card Oh played the
King to h1 just good prophylaxis to make
sure they're there won't be any tempos
if indeed rook c3 does come but Bishop
e5 prepares blacks own blockade if the
Queen comes to d6 hitting h2 right if
this H for this is a WoW in the before
in this match
wait often just feel so so loose okay I
mean there's there is no Queen f6
because of Bishop c5 but you start
extending your King in these types of
time controls even if there are no
tactics immediately as both so it is
yeah you got you got your book III I was
gonna say it's both sides gonna deter
time pressure White's King only becomes
more more vulnerable so what's the issue
here yeah I can't think I love it and I
feel like there we go
I didn't get my queen of six but I've
got my hit on h4 I don't like this at
all for Recaro to be honest I don't
understand what he's doing and why he
did it looks looks suspicious he's
losing anymore with check so Queen h4
look ain't read on yeah I guess he has
to play rook page three I guess if I
move my queen you're taking b4 so at
least you have that so right but if I
feel like if I set things up properly
with either Queen f or g for both moves
have their purpose queen g4 allows rook
c8 with the secon I'm like just saying
rook b8 here first I don't know right
just guarding there's the plant okay now
he decides he's gonna go for it and he
wants the threat on f7 you know but I
mean I'm not convinced here saying that
for white come on as everyone just now
black has to deal with both the threat
on f7 and the b4 pawn guys see pawn has
passed that dark squares are weak look
at that maneuver defending f7 with tempo
I'm on because in the Queen check on 81
that's how you do it
so can you get away with rook takes
before I'm assuming the answer is no but
I'm also assuming he's thinking about
that right because it deals with Queen
each one in a way and it also takes that
pawn which I'm sure you're dying today
so I'm sort of line like this might be
possible but it still feels like black
is really bringing the heat so he does
take it but I mean why it's just
basically getting naked here how do we
how do we avoid it so rook t1 really is
a checkmate a little Queenie one make
sure so if yeah so if Queen takes c3 for
example which stops that and they you
don't start with rook t1 but you start
with Queen h1 and then you put your hook
on d2 which is good in this makes we
would have this check
followed by rook d2 and like that's okay
so I think this is just winning after a
20 minute rookie to Queen h1 King F to
Rupp d2 is just easy and king e to
there's either route d2 which is good
enough or queen takes to or Bishop t2
and it's even faster than made only one
can't be stopped Queenie I can't I can't
get one right there to good Queen a one
Queen h1 just wins the well we won't
hold it against you because at that
point you were picking between apples
and oranges and what do we have here
I've truly back and forth match with
maxime holding his first lead since the
2-1 lead that he had for those of you
just getting here and again I asked him
on my therapist to tell me what I'm
feeling and it's not to dye my hair
it's just that vaccine might might
actually have a chance today right
what's the how much time do we have left
in the five minute here I uh let me
check on me on the time control here we
have how much this is probably like they
only have a couple more games in than I
would bet has to be going
I would guess probably to two more games
in the end of five minutes so enough
time for a comeback and you asked a good
question the timer seems to not be not
be visible here
on our on our template I think I just
saw about 22 23 to 23 minutes yeah okay
well we'll work on that
not sure where that went but from all of
our donations coming in I haven't read
all the messages with them but but we do
appreciate it
birthday birthday to Big Foot well-known
streamer donation on behalf of on half a
big foots birthday for the match thank
you for that whoever gave that but all
right so we're back to another stubborn
opening where again I I feel like a car
oh well he's not getting as much as he
did as white from my perspective in the
in the white side of the grünfeld but he
is he is doing just fine his black hair
right now that's that's definitely true
and I think that's been true every time
we've we've seen them play this line
that he hasn't had his issues actually
it's the games where he cars been white
have been the most competitive for
either player to score and results it's
what it looks like so far
he's hitting the Rockland a2 here which
is why you can get away with this this
b5 move d5 oh he would love to put a
knight on c5 here if I could just if I
could just achieve that I mean we're
probably gonna see maybe Queens see one
I'm not sure not sure if he wants to
keep putting pressure on c7
with the idea that he stops a Knight d7
because if he doesn't then 97 and 95
when b6 happens and it feels like black
just exerts everything on the F file on
the Kings side he's got that night
covering a for an e4 it feels like you
can't let that happen so he's played
Queen c12 stop the move Knight d7
stopping the knight from getting to to
c5 Queen d7 King g2 s certainly gonna be
played and I think he's gonna follow up
with like rook C to f8 potentially or
Knight h5 in to f4 there's some some
pretty good attacking options with like
net h5 Knight f4 sacrifice and Queen
takes h3 so I think he's planning
something like that
but if she makes I mean if and the makes
black play the movie six by you know 93
maneuver or something or 94 then what's
gonna happen is the c6 square can be
occupied before the c5 square so it's
kind of who gets to operate on the C
file the way they want to the men blacks
position would be so good if you could
just get that night to c5 the rook is
defended here so there's no tricks like
if the rook was was not defended by
these T's night so then I might be more
interested in some sort of sacrifice 9
h5 still looks interesting but it seems
like the way that white has these bonds
arranged h3 g3 even a knight on h2 most
of the sacrifices aren't too convincing
and it's still this pipeline dream of 97
95 but that's why MV Allah is staying
with the Queen uncie one in Brooklyn c2
he just can't let the net move a 97
happen because then the pawn would be
undefended in a lot of cases you can
give up the pawn not not that I'm
advocating for it here but in some cases
the knight on c5 is so worth it you can
play move like 97 rotate c7 and just
play 95 just to get your piece there but
I actually like the way that nvl has
handled things so far because he's not
allowing 97 to happen and with this
exchange it looks like that's gonna be
confirmed it's definitely not gonna
happen
and I think White has the upper hand
he's got that pressure on c7 probably
got the favorable King side structure in
the knight on g6 is what it's concerning
me I don't see a good home for that
piece g6 it's not very impressive it has
to go Knight FA 97 95 and again the way
that White's arranged his pieces is
exactly to prevent that
and c1h five okay once once the night to
come into both h4 and EV for tactics
packets tactics I mean he's got this
night at four move but I'm not sure how
I feel it first of all I think we have
to take it I'm not sure that that
there's another option earlier that in
the position the reason that Queen g5
was able to be played was rook c7 rook
takes Queen takes Queen takes D to the
knight was hanging but he didn't like
dealing with the move Knight f4 so he's
actually decided to sacrifice a pawn
here temporarily surprising I'm not sure
what the follow-up was if he had I like
the move H for a lot I think that's I
think that's very correct if you take on
g4 there 93 follows yeah and even if you
play I don't yeah I don't know I even if
you play that position it feels like the
pawn on g4 is is too weak but maybe that
was correct
Brooke f3 also would have been possible
just because of the c7 upon hanging so
maybe he just didn't want to lose the G
pawn right back instead leaves white
with these trap GG pawns right right no
I line here the night wants to reroute
Knight h7 Knight f6 where it's gonna do
a lot 93 is never a concern because
black just plays g6
totally dominates the five square and
therefore the the III knight in general
so g6 just uh gonna hold your ground
I guess move saying you can't play
Knight of three anyway because g4 Falls
so what useful moves does white have in
this position here I say none right no
no good moves right it's tough
he's just doing a prep move but the
question is with this you know
quote-unquote extra pawn sitting on c7
you know it's not really an extra pawn
but it feels like it you know what's
more impressive the pawn on g3 or the
pawn on c7 neither I plead the fifth
exactly so even if you win the G pawns
you're your majority on the queenside is
next to next to no value and so you're
only extra pawn might be the g7 pawn if
you
lucky to win both and that might not be
enough to win yeah but if anything I'll
just say that black is is pushing to my
eyes
he can play 97 95 it wasn't nice that's
where to spit on that's not a nice he
attacks some really annoying pawns to
defend yeah so one follows everything
changes so white could not allow that so
now he probably wants to potentially
just bring his king at least to e7 maybe
even a d7 and then you can think about
things like rook f8 Brooke h8 Queen h6
that Queen on c2 is completely stuck on
that exact square that exact square I
love that what is of both a4 and e4 I
should say not that exact sir I guess
Queen c4 could be played but you know if
you're shuffling between those two
squares avocado oh okay now he decides
you can do it and the reason is that 94
is not a threat due to Queen coming
right back to c2 and the pony is pinned
but but you can't have that yeah it's
just just a fancy tickle because you
can't do anything with it okay so now
Queen D ones not possible don't forget
right now the queen is defended that was
the point
Queen age 7 is still hitting and now
work age 6 yeah if he goes on to like
this game this is this has been a very
work h1 is it playable Knight h4 might
have happened but I was ready to
sacrifice yeah that would have been
interesting but I guess from what the
other perspective he's gone from being
down in time to no up on the clock come
on so he's like why change anything
right just keep keep assist very
uncomfortable for y again there you okay
I think this is on the way to losing I
think the queen will go into g4 yeah
after this one deaf to Queen g4 yet yeah
what it's almost okay surprised that it
came so early do not surprise given the
direction of the game but we're back to
a tied match that was a very nice game
for Nakamura I think that's a really
important game for the match that should
give him a lot of confidence
what does not give me confidence
cheering for Nakamura is this line I
don't have to see it again he's not
playing now we have almost 6,000 of you
a very very interesting approach today
by both players knocking
perhaps showing that he that he had some
preparation in the fact that he has only
played this system is white what you're
looking at so you haven't missed
anything but this system besides that in
Game one he played a different move
order which is his only win in this line
to this point so a1 and I alone a little
perplexed we are at and you know just if
you want some stats to prove what we
keep saying about this grin felt every
single one of the grunt felts has been a
win so it's like and in this match black
has won five of the eight decisive game
so here we have a completely original
now move
I'm sorry it's not a completely original
move completely original position given
that we've seen this line you know what
feels like a million times I'm starting
to feel like you know will grow and
felled expert here yeah it's like hey
you want to you want to go play somebody
you get a little uh a little frisky gear
yeah because this is a sideline so it's
not like you're gonna experience too
many different treatments of the
position that you see so Laura wouldn't
be going back to this consistently
totally against a lot of his other
approaches in these formats unless
unless he looked at it or unless he felt
somewhat confident here he does have a
slight edge I think if we were
evaluating objectively but um and and
and where did this one differ when he
really it looks like Maxime differed
with this move Queen h4 on Lou thirteen
but a cardinal is quickly enough to
suggest to you he kind of had been
prepared for that idea it's like I'm
gonna have to give a talk to these
players it's like guys stop changing
your moves when you won the left I know
right that's if it if it ain't broke
don't fix it I at you know pretty sure
somebody said that all right well b5 is
happening this is not our traditional
grünfeld battle where am on and I have
highlighted kind of a the two-on-one the
positional dole for black over here
white having to use the center you want
to really yeah this is much more crazy
so if Queen age five there was material
on the loose there right with ninety two
checked he was playing he's playing for
the compensation like if he took that
material which he's about to
he wants to say is Bishop e7 d6 like
that this just flows quite nicely so I
have to say that I've seen Hikaru played
this type of consistent theoretical
approach in these matches and and
suggesting frankly that that this is
prep I mean you see that confident an
exchange sack just quickly over the
board to do this right I mean it's you
tell me it it feels like feels like he
Caro has seen these positions before
still around 4 minutes and really trust
that white house enough compensation for
the exchange here yeah you might have
looked at I mean who knows how extensive
his prep in this line was he clearly
planned to play it for the match now we
don't know if he prepped it for the
match because these guys have knowledge
of sidelines right you know does it for
any other tournament right it just
happens to be anything it today right
but it seems like a great idea just the
premise of being totally comfortable in
a position where your opponent has not
looked at it as much as you let's say
just before the match maybe nvl knows
this line but if you think back to to
high school and studying for a test you
know if you cram the the stuff that's
not on the test you're not going to do
as well even listen you if you know it
Goldmember evergreen warrior saying that
if MBL in the chest TV chat if NBL gets
hit karo below 3000 he should feel good
about himself I don't think either one
of these guys are playing for a moral
victory what that connect collects his
rating but I know that he's certainly
yeah there's only a couple things in
life Nakamura loves more than his rating
and we're not supposed to talk about
either but you know but no I agree it
Cardone loves his rating but I don't
think Maxime really cares if Maxime said
you would have a lead headed into the
three-minute portion that's what he
wants yeah and at the end of the day
that's what a car wants because he knows
how often he's played MDL on chess calm
in some of these matches he knows that
this is the last quarterfinal match and
I witness takes him to the Sandi's
against Levon and and wants to punch his
ticket for I don't last last game of the
year Dan can't hold anything back now if
we say that mag
is not in the tournament then that's
back to - Nakamura you know his stomping
grounds yeah that's where he excels all
right well he's gonna win the e3 pawn
and probably have the kind of position
probably have the composition he
shouldn't lose his way but maybe not I
mean the one thing that black has going
for him is this grünfeld advantage that
you always have in this structure is
still just sitting over here on the
queenside the two-on-one is going to
give black long-term winning chances
yeah not even just because it's
two-on-one but the the a5 a4 maneuver is
so disruptive you know the bishop on b3
that's supported by Ponte - I there's
nothing more frustrating than being
dislodged like that because if you play
a3 suddenly white or black just brings a
rope to the third-ranked and you're so
disturbed dealing with that and if you
don't play a3 the a4 happens you get
kicked off to c2 or do you want and the
deep on just falls so I move I'm clearly
saying I know I'm in trouble I need to
try to hold a draw here yes yes I mean
a4 in the sense is he's kind of a good
move to deal with that but now your
bishop it is I was gonna say play Brooke
before the only feeling like this is
gonna be a harder position for black to
win now that the majority is gone he's
playing to win though he's not let's say
sacking on d5 or I don't know like
something maybe sacking on d5 actually
would lose the game after rook d5 but it
may be right being a pawn anything have
to calculate but you know I'm not here
to calculate for sure
anyway Wow he probably wants to play his
King into d6 but black black is too mean
definitely playing for the win here
rook f4 rook f6 is always something
calculated it's like it Tim am I
actually just getting in trouble here
nope not sure you want to trade those
rooks off and I see the time is
trickling down 8 minutes so we're
probably gonna get one one working I
guess it depends how how long it goes
but I think we're already like I know
that the score between these two and the
five-minute portion was 5-4
in the past so we're gonna get this game
plus one more so I think they're playing
already like way faster yeah and we had
a couple of those games that were draws
very quickly right and a couple of early
resignations in the sense that you know
once a player decided he was lost
they're not really interested in pushing
it on right so these guys are these guys
were pros we talked about it in our
pregame talk and you know like we said
the og just calm followers know that
since the invention pretty much of the
these these big events these guys have
played as much as anybody and they don't
no stranger to both how each other play
in about ninety games they've actually
played head-to-head by the way on the
chest comp server there have only been
18 draws well they play play decisive
chess and they and they know each other
well yeah and this is just just quite a
quite a nice move I think really deals
with the entire position
yeah threatening I think there's still a
lot of thanks we revived and just
simplify it out yeah team d6 you
definitely don't take with the bishop
because of king c5 but you take with the
rook you play this bishop against rook
endgame because I think the pawn on f4
does fall but that's that's the one to
catch you that I think so King d6 rook
b5 rupee five Bishop b5 let's say rook
takes d5 and then maybe I get my king to
to e5 yep I thought but that one would
have been inning but maybe at least
white could play he could arrange to
play g3 there and then you have rook
against Bishop which these guys know is
he's a draw he's really done a great job
of keeping the winning chances alive
here at being maxime now Brooke g3 I
think is coming it's gonna I think he's
gonna play rookie for yeah I thought I
thought maybe he should have claimed
rookie three first oh no key was in
check I'm done okay so he had no choice
but still that the threat of rookie
three is honestly what forced a car to
get the Brookes often so how's the
evaluation of this he's not going to get
the pawn on like at this point rook can
come to the 3rd range so his best
chances if you can somehow get the King
to the 3rd rank right so you're gonna
check
back the problem is if you could if you
could do something like king h4 and
actually check this King back okay you
might be able to establish King g3 the
problem is over a way to ever give check
to this King without it coming forward
so yeah I think okay now definitely if
that bishop gets to f3 we can we can all
agree ashtag right it's a draw I think
that he wants to play okay yeah I don't
think whiteness really wants to put the
bishop on f3 because what happens Danny
as I play rook C to check Bishop e2 King
e41 it's really uncomfortable for you
and if you have to bring the King back
then I just put King III so I think
that's actually like it feels
comfortable but it's actually maybe a
way to lose right so but as long as the
bishop just maintains itself on whether
it's the d1 h5 or flipping quickly to
the a e8h one diagonals I think what's
important to remember is that black
cannot be allowed to play the move King
to e4 or G win white when white cannot
like give it right let's see 4 or
g4 right so the bishop has to be in a
position that's why he's hanging around
back there trying to get some checks and
you also go to eat you notice yep now
you could but otherwise you want to
leave the f3 Square vacant for the King
right so you can actually go up the
board as opposed to down which is what
he just did right and again the main
reason for that everybody is if Black
gets the king to either a v-square
though this is this an issue
oh you plundered the tempo now that King
was getting to g4 I'm not sure it's
really frustrated with himself you're
asked to put the bishop on of three but
now after rook check I think you can
play BB - yeah he gets lucky so after
rookie to Bishop e2 if black could just
put the King on e4 like before it was
they would be losing for what this is
fortunate because Ruby - there's King f3
so despite his frustration socorro is
actually just fine yeah
you still get frustrated because you
know that that's simply but no but this
has been pretty instructive and I think
that we all want to see the blunders in
the excitement but seeing strong players
like this hold positions that are you
know very very dangerous but there
holding with very little time on the
clock and what I was about to say
everybody is the black King gets here
and there is no check that's the recipe
to success because white will be forced
to to give ground so this whole dance
that's going on is is really interesting
to see how these players are both aware
of what the other side's goal position
is and that's sometimes how you can
calculate a high-level you have to be
aware of what your opponent wants in
order to know how to stop it right
Brooke d8 is he gonna try I don't think
it matters though is the king if the
king is on this side now we know the
bishop can always walk on e2 the King
has to be threatening to get to e4 yeah
the or will that problem is there's so
many checks from efore this to two
diagonals I'll check from which is why
he's finding no no luck there it's
actually black who's almost you think
flagged here pretty funny right now all
the sudden Maxime Maxime forgetting that
he could lose on time as long as white
has that that pawn on g2 so yeah but
okay I wonder if they've repeated the
position three times enough yet what do
you think of the rook on the sixth ring
like it feels like that's the operative
nobody I think you have to be able to
get the row to the sixth rank and have
the King on the call it the the center
side of the pond with frets of e4 right
right so he's trying to create that but
now the King will come back the bishop
comes back to e8 preparing to meet king
knee forward bishop g6 yeah oh that's a
surprising way to end and we to end up
getting this we do end up getting this
one more game but we were almost wrong
there that was almost the longest game
in the history of the the five-minute
portion a month Wow well we have a tied
match which I mean regardless of the
result of this game and I don't want to
give him any any victories he hasn't
earned yet but if you were to tell
Maxime he would be in a tied or or one
game match headed into three-minute I
mean at this point given his record
again socorro in these matches I think
he's got to be feeling pretty good about
his chances yep no I agree
I don't think that he could be upset so
far I'm interested going in 3 minute
because the last time that they played
hakuro actually set an incredible pace
true he really separated from Maxime at
that time control after a very close 5
minute which is echoing what we're
seeing here I also wonder whether the
openings are gonna stay the same or if
there's like sort of a different
three-minute repertoire because it seems
like MDL is willing to follow the lead
of noir Iranian Cotto kind of setting
the pace with openings and we'll see how
long that happens what is this rook e 2
rooks e2 did we see this last game and I
just didn't notice it we didn't I am I
mean okay last game I was I was fixing
an issue for a moment but I this has
clearly gone wrong here for Maxine this
is the worst part seen in this line so
far efore is falling for free but f2 is
hanging right right what Knight takes f2
hello Picaro is calculating with his
hair blowing in the wind trying to
figure out what in the world Maxie what
just happened there no but why is there
a Brooklyn c2 I mean I played the Benko
before and sometimes you do like some
funny stuff like that but otherwise
you're I felt like that almost sounded
like a confession coming out of your
mouth I played the Benko before oh it's
not the benoni but that was the bass
that's definitely too fast long time for
another one no there isn't there isn't
must have been close though that's
insane you're right I'm gonna go ahead
and check real quick on the players
scoreboard and make sure that that is by
far the worst like if I I know the time
is up time is up and okay that's that's
after everything that you did that's
probably the last possible way you want
to enter the three-minute as mvl there
okay well a very strange way to bring
our five-minute portion to a close but
our players have been updated that they
are officially on a break and they may
take a quick step away so right as we
said MBL feels like he or he should be
feeling confident
what's happened to this point he loses
his quickest game in the match so far
him on with the white pieces so I given
that and the fact that we've talked
about Hikaru strengths in three minutes
yes perhaps being better than almost
five minute or bullet in this particular
format we've seen him put up some really
dominant performances yeah I think we're
gonna find out very quickly as we start
the next segment whether Maxime is gonna
continue to make this a back and forth
affair so don't go anywhere
seven thousand of you that are with us
on chess comm TV twitch TV slash chess
Aman and I will be right back along with
our super grandmasters with a three
minute portion and we are back as we
head into the three minute portion only
a one-game lead right now or the the
overall one seed of the entire speed
chess championship racket this year
Hakkar Nakamura but for those of you who
may doesn't look like many of you have
gone anywhere but if you did happen to
just join us then you missed that very
very shocking end to the five minute
portion in an opening here that we've
seen both sides play several times in a
very stubborn speed chess match so far
right Aman we see just a shocking
maneuver from vaccines starting with
this move rook to e2 that whatever
reason he grew impatient with the
position that had been working okay for
him is white puts the rook on an awkward
Square and falls prey to very quick
tactics Bishop to g4 and then the center
opens up and suddenly black is just up a
free pawn rook rook e2 2 c2 is
definitely not something he invented
it's obviously and I like and ideally
must've right he knows but he's mistimed
it completely and it's resulted in one
of the quickest five-minute games that
I've personally ever seen him well it's
a good lesson for all of us even the
best can either forget their prep or
confuse their prep but it reminds us the
principles are real and when you make
awkward moves like that usually the best
way to punish your opponent is to open
the center quickly and that's why the
karo did so let's put that knowledge in
our in our pocket and exchange it later
the currency rate is pretty good right
now as far as knowledge goes um on our
players are ready they are back at it
we've had $29 donated to the overall
price 1 starting with the 3
Rand um what if I Ches calm for the Ford
this particular match the overall speech
has championship rages on so if you like
what you see let that let the players
know how much you love them thank you
for being here and we're back to the
grünfeld
I think that those donations maybe came
from like Grunfeld in Italian players
own right of the how many games we had
of the 12 games I think we've had eight
grünfeld and two and it's it's either
been the Grunfeld or gioco piano yeah
yeah no question about it the line that
we're seeing on the board is repeated
and I mean he's hey Carlo I mean has no
doubt what first of all he's improved by
the Danny Ranch method Queen f3 okay now
he's the d8 same line but White's up a
tempo so you were trolling me when you
said you thought the rook was better
placed on da right or worse place on da
well yes but I told you afterwards Oh
sometimes you know what I told you about
this humor you have from Canada
sometimes it just goes right over this
Americans head kind of like how Canada
is our hat did you sit up there and keep
keep us warm right where we're always
over you're always over my head
in Canada in fact today you're almost
directly over my head you're in Calgary
you're on the west coast of Canada
that's true yeah west coast Mountain
Time mountain time well alright the
truth is I didn't know but it was clear
that hikaru needed to improve on the
last time he had this position he has
done so and he might be about to win his
second game in a row I feel much better
about white chances here than I have
since probably the first grünfeld game
that he had in this land yep this looks
good he probably literally plugged his
game in and said wait a minute I looked
at this pre-match you know what's what's
the deal yeah like why am i not just
better and now he's like oh I'm not
better because I've been messing up the
line and now I'm gonna crush him he
fixed one thing and I think this is just
game over
take aged five this is just resigned
times and all of a sudden I'm Brooke
aged six as well was actually the mate
there yeah that would have been rude
page six and Bishop f6 that would have
been nice too bad they ended quickly
buddy but I would have showed you two
made too late the next game has started
now did he have time to plug in this
position on and the L side he's probably
like he's like oh so this is where the
rookie 2 C 2 was supposed to have well
for the first time I'm wondering if
we're seeing a little bit of a Maxine
tilt there I mean these have been two
very very quick losses he either needs
to change the guard and get away from
these openings that Hikaru is stubborn
to go back to or show us that we're
wrong right we haven't had a three-game
lead in the match yet for either player
but the three-minute portion is where
naca really does I mean when you think
about naca playing on chess con he plays
3 minutes and he plays bullets he
doesn't play 5 min yep when he plays in
the grand chess to her eye he plays like
three plus two yep so so the five
minutes are you believe the time control
if we could say this about Nakamura that
he's not as accustomed to right so it's
a good point now he's in the zone yeah
now he feels in the zone and we have a
question on on Twitch how much do you I
have to donate to get these guys to play
a different opening well even though
we're not gonna tell them not to so I
can't really say but well let's just say
that it's got to be more than $29 so
keep trying yeah exactly
clearly they haven't gotten the message
yet so all right this is good this is
gonna be an instructive one you've got
this d3 pawn for the b6 pawn as far as
weaknesses being traded then I don't
have five super useful because it guards
the d6 square yeah and a quarter wants
to get rid of it so that he can actually
double or before he's given the d3 pawn
but it's a very temporary thing that the
night would come to c4 now you would
have to take the d1 rook and then play
Knight to c8 to not lose material but
this night on g6 is so clumsy they would
follow like moves like rook d7 85 so the
general feeling is that I like white
because especially after that that's a
positional win to rid yourself of this
week pawn here if you don't play that by
the way I play the move a knight c6 king
f7 you know double rooks and the D file
suddenly maybe black this is favor but
this definitely looks good for for Maxie
nothing special though I'll say I mean
let's remember totally symmetrical here
better pieces for white but no material
advantage yep but as you mentioned this
could open up the first three gyal
though it looks doubtful that Nakamura
is gonna be the one to win but the first
three-game lead of the match and just
from a sort of psychological standpoint
from the L side you don't want to let
that happen absolutely and and again it
wouldn't be wouldn't just be
psychological it would be the first
mathematical three game lead we've had
which you know it's just it's hard to
overcome Danny what what's the deal with
these glasses so NACA started the match
with glasses on orange glasses like
Jimmy Neutron or something else and then
he lost two games and then he took them
off and we've never seen them again yeah
you know I think as we know the karo has
been known to sport interesting attire
when it when he comes to the board and
um but if it's not going well I don't
know if a car would admit this but I
think he's a relatively superstitious
player either way let's remind everybody
since you brought it up that we do have
a Photoshop contest going on we have the
legendary Jaron himself throwing a snap
section of a coming garnier commercial
there looks very very realistic with
that all that hair blowing in the wind
in a corner hang it up you didn't know
but I had brought that up earlier
plastic stuff here from jaren anybody
else who wants to get involved in our
Photoshop contest these were the glasses
hey Cara was wearing earlier we will
bring up some of the latest entries and
and show you
well actually Jaron has I mean most of
the Photoshop is gonna be on Nakamura
because it was the hair in the glasses
but Jaron is actually in possession of
something that he tweeted at mvl uh-huh
which is a Photoshop that he did of MDL
back when he played the deal turn so I
think it's like MBL's face photoshopped
on some guiding or something well we
can't even compete right now with the
the Spanish broadcasts are
Luis is is over there just dominating
the other Twitter the the Spanish chess
community following us always seems to
be the most active with the hashtag
during these events and but there are
also some gifts if you go far enough and
now there you go
alright well back to the game here where
we're having a very quick Peter into a
night ending but with Maxine maintaining
minimal winning chances perhaps an extra
pawn likely done during our delve into
the Garnier advertisement campaigns we
actually missed quite a lot of
everything is sort of evaporated it was
a fight quickly I classified it's pretty
pretty good winning chances just because
of how far the black king is but it
really depends on this pawn on h5
whether it can be removed for example
he's contending h4 where you can't play
g4 that's what he wants Wow well we've
had two of our biggest donations they
heard the call when you said $29 wasn't
enough um on the st. says this is solid
honeymoon entertainment look at that
washing us with hopefully his his
newlywed bride if you're spending a lot
of alone time away from your bride on
your honeymoon
protip give her some attention um and
then Adriano for MVP gives us a $20
donation a month in support of such a
great chest Hanul he likes our
commentary this guy thank you thank you
both for being amazing there you go just
had to just have to get the the photo
shot I see gerunds in the chat there
they can paste it and chest baby
reposted that was the one I was talking
about yeah from bill well I agree with
you that the winning chances are based
on this king being so far away but still
feel I have a hard time believing black
can't just be ready to give up both
nights for both pawns right that's the
key because for those of you who know
your basic mates there is no way to
checkmate with Chile you have to do two
things though Danny you have to give
both nights up and get rid of your pot
right and that's what he tried to do
with the move h4 and that's actually
really good point bayamón oh my back up
and show that that that's why black
doesn't just take here and take here
because now you have a position where
white will not capture this pawn and I'm
not sure on the theory of this am on I
forget I think
to the fourth-ranked is actually far
enough that it's still at raw but I
don't remember exactly there are all
kinds of mating that's possible ok and
now we have Eric actually had this
position during an Olympiad yeah in 2014
and he wasn't even I mean I had know
nothing about the actual intricacies of
doing it I could try but it's a one of
the most complicated and amusing chefs
it was a strange thing they they
rematched and then aborted and we
matched each other again but I'd away
the next game continues in well the
color didn't change right sometimes
that's a that's the tactic right you
like Oh abort
oh sorry and then you hit him with that
double white remark lol lol and
labactive Bishop e3 no 92 continuing
here but hey Carl took my my advice and
played Queen of three directly which has
improved his winning chances maxing
better better not repeat that exact game
where he lost almost as quickly as he
did the end of five minute or ssin yeah
this now it's like okay Maxime what do
you have you know he comes up with his
Queen a5 the only thing I'll say is that
what Nakamura brought to the table as an
improvement was in my opinion checked
during the break he looked at it with a
computer I want to say which is why he
was confident bringing it out whereas MV
ELLs improvement right now he likely
found right now so the the upper hand in
terms of the position probably still
lies it in Hikaru's favor
preparation yeah yeah he's comfy he's
probably just looked at it
whereas nvl was getting great positions
so you know he's not gonna like stare at
this position during the break that
wasn't where he went wrong and then
after our last two donations the the
legendary chess pay the the twitch the
twitch hemispheres greatest chess
philanthropist donates 33,000 bits we
love you yes BAE and thank you for
everyone's support here of these players
and for helping to increase the price
won the prize fund counts the the bits
as well as yeah that's it yep anything
even purchases on the merch store and
aren't always gets mad at me when I say
that because that means we have to track
another another system but hey purchases
of the merch store if you decide you
want to speak
just mug I have one being sent to you
Aman relax relax okay was the boats of
the up in arms yeah so what and anything
you want today is all going to the
players so alright hey car oh gosh was
this was a big mistake
yeah this is this is this is the kind of
exchange sack you you fantasize about on
the white side of the gun filled this is
the potential three-game bringing lead
that we talked about this King can put
itself on d3 this LightSquared Bishop
was the best piece on the board there's
nothing here there's nothing and you can
always do that very nice maneuver with
your light square Bishop where you can
like either stick it on b5 or c6
depending which file you want to clog
let's say and just the king - king d3
like you said this piece just I mean so
we just have another another $30
donation Wow the fans are liking it
there they they're givin these players
their love in our last match of the
quarterfinals today so well support is
rolling in people need you to age also
with the the resub shut up b th and what
is white doing here dude do wait do i
have to try to corral this pawn but king
f2 doesn't work because of Bishop c5
check
oh so Maxie making this hard for
Nakamura to prove right so a 6 my
question is what what about the obvious
like I'm just gonna push my pawn all the
way I can play Bishop d7 I don't know
what what to do about this yeah I was
gonna say Ruth you one is a 7
you know after trading or at any point
there's always a Bishop c5 yeah Shak no
cheap so v1 is nice especially if you if
you get the rope behind the pawn this is
always your best way to try to approach
a passed pawn race if you can you're
relying upon and help yours how is teeny
one I want to try my best to lose the
game like you wanna get yourself made on
c1 check we should see one issue of each
stick yeah and then I'm like wow so what
a weird configuration here ok so we got
the pawn and he'll be happy about that
but I think white is just by still
better than
the deep one will eventually fall you
still have to pass not to pass bombs
excuse me but two pawns in in
compensation cakes you though he does
get something Roque to king D three
Brooke G to but I think that NACA was
saying like he just takes that six let's
say and he's got two connected passed
pawns that role yeah
our last thirty dollar donation came to
us and and asking if we could get hit
car to play the bond cloud opening he
says he saw him play the bond cloud
opening in his own stream one time and
it was hilarious
anyway thanks for the commentary well we
appreciate it unfortunately we can't
really advise these players on what
openings we want them to played but that
is you guys are giving me like more
ideas for a future format where we
actively engaged choices like that I
think there's there's a ton on the line
here with a huge prize fund for any kind
of online event and and the title of the
sec so we're not gonna influence bad
openings but i like i like where your
head's at well dan do you just say bad
opening let's not go down the bond cloud
road right now alright so mcaro has his
two passers will it be enough he's gonna
want to get the bishop to the h3c a
diagonal
you can't take if you remember one thing
to remember about advancing these ponds
is that based on the fact that black
possesses a dark square bishop normally
there he got to it yeah on the dark
squares a car was slightly frustrated
with that he's got to be annoyed right
yeah that was a game he liked his
exchange sack and and maxime defended
well well you gotta be happy with that
if you're maxine you stave off what
looked like a terrible position and now
you get two white pieces again so well
we have a our first my eyes hurt is this
a different opening the first berlin i
think right well i soon was a berlin i
yes it was indeed and we've got the
opening that for those of you who really
follow all of our all of our events for
the last few years you know that the
last time hikaru and maxine played their
speech just match it felt like a berlin
theoretical battle we had a lot of
Berlin's back and forth and
this is the first one of today huh what
is these guys are both Berlin experts
hey Carl getting look at that that's a
car number seven I've told you it would
come a car number seven is to look off
to the side over the right shoulder
trying to recall opening theory has
anybody started the wiki page I asked
for all these cattle you know I'm uh I'm
cataloging these the car number seven is
always a theory check there it is oh
that's a car number 14 look up and over
that's actually him pretending to be
frustrated but he's actually questioning
his opponents move he knows exactly what
he's doing
actly I don't let's say Danny I'll play
dumb here yo I don't know much about the
Berlin so I were gonna say a car with
faces I'm like yes you do
well he only has one face when he plays
me it's that one affliction is what is
going on here
satisfaction but what why is like why is
black not okay like completely okay
let's say because I've got this extra
pond yeah it looks to me like the worst
that's gonna happen is I'm gonna lose g5
and not it not a lot of stuff what
happens after I mean f6 yeah I don't
disagree I think it's a you know that's
one of the reasons but I plays this
system where they take they grab the
pawn so early this is kind of what
defines the Berlin everybody if you
follow the analysis board and if white
doesn't guess no pressure of a small
development lead then things tend to
simplify very quickly
well Queen f6 would win like the game if
not I think 95 Bishop T fat Bishop e5 I
DS the line at exactly 5:55 with tempo
and then I gobble bass yeah right so
actually this was what I was interested
in wait you guys we have a crease anger
peace
we have our first our first queen sac
like I like this a lot for for black
that's hard for me to justify that the
calls were donations on behalf of the
Queen sac because this is just good for
black this is white sacrifice this is
white being worse and and Accardo
quickly recognizing the opportunity for
an edge in the endgame
yeah no this is this is just comfortable
and it really is three pieces against
the queen and you're gonna find pretty
soon like you're gonna get a master
class display of how I might like you
only a queen useless in this position so
I might even play a six as long as he's
insured that he can get the bishop to
this f1 yeah queen d3 is an issue yeah
okay so not right away so the car
recognized that balls for a different
fork though he just missed that yeah he
he's really upset and MVL is like
counting his lucky everything feels like
well I probably can't lose this anymore
he's okay because he's gonna sack a
piece for the pawn and then probably MBO
cannot win the endgame like I assumed so
it he could play like his Bishop on d5
here and he's just completely okay but
yeah two bishops for the Queen he'll
play it but there's nothing happening a
car a really frustrated if you follow
the analysis board it really the blunder
happened back here when when he allowed
a double attack on the bishop and the
pawn and we we thought we were about to
see a masterclass of how miners outplay
the Queen but this is still an
instructive moment when you recognize
that the the dogmatic extra points right
Queen's worth nine bishops were six not
really as valuable is the fact that
white just doesn't really have enough
targets when there's no other weaknesses
on the board so in theory unless black
creates problems for himself this this
should be totally holdable for black yep
yeah he's definitely gonna play it from
a car's respect like much to your point
if a draw was offered here by a car oh
I'm pretty sure he would take it yeah
yeah the ones you said it's a car oh not
white no hikaru is not white all right
yeah
the negative question is he not and I
know is it it is like a Jeopardy
question you asked the question in the
form of providing the answer
maxime vache lagravis white who was not
hit hard on camera yeah I don't see
anything happen here I mean if he's
interested he can play f6 just to yeah
just to really make sure it gets easy
I'm in Memphis
oh cool says he would blunder his queen
and lose this position as white you're
not alone there buddy not alone you see
just gonna take on that six here pick up
six Bishop takes f6 he'll take with the
Queen it'd be a fun way to end this and
do a draw no Maxine wants more
I mean let's say that you take the g5
pawn off play king g6 and then Bishop e7
and I think they'll enter the draw
thank you okay yeah it seems like he
doesn't want to do that like he might
check and play Queen e5 I mean okay I
guess with a one justification as Hikaru
has 30 seconds and so you know he's you
know just cuz it is a draw in theory
doesn't mean the game is going to end in
a draw right so that's what Maxime is
gonna try to do create some practical
chances if King e8 white would've had
King g7 there and then it would have
been weird so suddenly Maxime making a
little bit of progress uh-huh
yeah and Joshua Chamberlain strikes
again we said the game was over that's
an inside joke come on I'm not sure if
you caught that one the Joshua Chaya
I caught nothing he's a legend
Chamberlain okay I'll take your word oh
the pawn advance is another square now
it's really really getting toasty for
black this is a weird position because
the the King just shuffles up and down
and the white king just can't go past
that that's the issue it would be more
interesting if the pawn was not on the
board so now he's playing for the win by
the way yeah suddenly uh okay I think
for a win is obviously a stretch but job
you don't disrespect naca yeah as soon
as you play encore don't think akaru is
not fantasizing about the bishops
relocating to c7 and c6 the pawn moving
up another two squares look at this
don't think
it's happening okay the Queen's gonna
come to a four though threatening Queen
d8 minute and I think that we will
finally see Maxine Hale knows Fisher CA
check if you take it look at that
classic akaru huh aha DL twitch chat
says she loves this imbalance and I
didn't think it was much of an imbalance
but perhaps she's right time look at
this Oh
oh man awesome okay now yeah now Queen
eight you came back to be eight and
Bob's your uncle
okay wait a minute what okay now there
there is no idea of bringing the King
forward with some sort of made on a
seventh because black Queens would check
on she wants cuz even here you can't
take that pawn there's always Bishop d7
wait a sec wait a second Queen h8 oh my
gosh oh my gosh Chikara plundered it Oh
oh my gosh and he's smiling and he's
just like oh oh man oh gee and you could
see Maxime sort of bouncing I started as
soon as the king went to a8 I was like
wait a second Queen h8 is a very holy
shenanigans and Joshua Chamberlain truly
does strike again we called a draw we
were wrong
the game ends in a win it seems like
both players at different points thought
they were winning and then losing I
think they both might have been at some
point I mean wow but MBL justified for
his continuation of a position that
seemed to be a draw the the fun and
excitement continues the chess calm OMG
email sentiment out it meant it to play
that on like I would assume that two
bishops and a pawns like why am I even
right table rook c8 now being played
differently than B for those of us who
are really take okay efore Queen of
three white is it's a slightly different
move order but all of us who are taking
advantage of the grünfeld lesson we're
getting here from DC players let me
remind you that normally before was the
move there
instead of rook c8 so maxime deciding he
doesn't want to keep getting that
position mixing it up okay this we've
seen this type of position before and
yet actually this was the case where
Hikaru played them of ePHI like with the
Queen on d6 that's sort of this feels
like a slight improvement for a car
because there there isn't a okay there
isn't a super rush happening with the a
pawn a pawn and beep on the normal
two-on-one front of the Grunfeld in a
car well he identified something which i
think is is completely true which is
that the bishop is completely in 100%
better on d2 than f2 I think that's the
case rook c8 was played to stop Bishop
c3 by the bias that would have been that
would have been a problem some activity
to deal with but Queen D is oh I thought
you could trade cuz rook d4 didn't
skewer due to reco 3 but and now he's
now he's getting the lady chased a
little bit that's Queen d8 where is this
Bishop going though okay so Queen d8
he's gonna go for this
I guess he's taking very scary though
yeah Queen takes you and rook c1 is
super scary because it's very for black
to I mean f5 is a move to to look out
for here and then f6 and smoke the King
out of his corner yes we've seen we've
seen some very impressive sprints so far
yup
f5 Queen d2 f6 King h6 Queen d7
threatening Queen h3 maybe you can just
play rook c1 there though showing that
on the board and he may be right we'll
find out what these two want but at
carro taking his time I was anticipating
he probably was calculating it and he's
gonna go for it yep so that is that
position that I just mentioned actually
looks like a draw with perpetual at the
end yeah maybe black mage week 85 and
white has to bail out right right I'm
not sure if that it's necessarily the
line we're gonna get - black doesn't
have to play ritzy weren't but because
here I'm sure there's another move then
let's see one which can be played
I don't know I'm more skeptical that the
black is the one pushing on I think if
Brooke see one on the analysis board
queen h3 King g5 okay could I play g3
just stay with me here
g3 guarding f1 with the Queen also
threatening Queen h4 mate I know what
you're thinking
Danny no but Queen h3 and g3 no I I
assumed that he can probably play it or
or queen of three check guards the rook
with tempo I like that maxime should
have gone to HS h 6 1 our Queen h4 so
now now he gets the tempo guarding the
brook and I feel like white is the one
pushing here yep yeah the only thing is
if he gets to an endgame
I'm potentially still concerned about
like a Bishop d6 covering everything
perfectly and a bishop on t1 just being
out of the game but that's a good point
and white may end up regretting the
darks we're opening he just started with
with h4 but like if yeah I was gonna say
if you even take the rook on f1 and then
click Bishop d6 or just like Bishop d6 a
little uncomfortable
Bishop d3 ok Hikaru knows what what you
said to be true he can't afford to just
be down a piece and the Alpes code
Bishop physicians if the play becomes
all about your opponent's squares then
you're basically down a piece so I
offered to draw interesting that's
incepted the car shaking his head you
know I'm not gonna I don't think I'm out
on a limb here say that game was almost
a bit of a hangover a game for Recaro
after blundering that last one we saw
with the Queen for the two bishops right
the emotional carryover from losing that
last game that he should know but let's
not forget that that Maxine is is going
like completely toe-to-toe with Nakamura
right now yeah this is a one you game
match one game match with the 30 minutes
left and a time control that has been
historically a car was bread and butter
here Maxime not blundering into his
rookie to Brooksie to approach this time
we have a different move order for those
of you who've been with us since the 5
minute portion thank you to all 8,000 of
you with us now
all the donate
and bits that have added more than a
hundred bucks here to the players
pockets and what's the highest view
count for one of these one of the events
I assumed it would be the the NACA
against Magnus oh oh for sure I thought
you meant this year yeah I would have to
ask this year because that would be yeah
yeah no growth both of the finals for
the speech Chess Championships have been
our I think historically the highest
view chess events that any of us have
ever been lucky to be above and we were
you know crossing almost 40,000 peak
viewers but um I don't know this year
you know but either way we love
everybody that's here today and now
we're in that this is more of a dynamic
struggle with the pawn structures in the
center that we've had so far with white
getting this early night on at 5:00 yeah
now one thing about these these kind of
positions I was going to say what the
bishops still on the board the pressure
on the e5 pawn is the only thing
preventing me from playing Bishop takes
f5 ef5 and then play Knight FA yeah
something like that because if I could
get away with that structurally that F
pond it's not so good for white but it
would come at the price f1 pawn closes
the center rather than trying to
undermine things like c5 and I think I
think it's the right choice because now
white feels that with the pawns closed
up I'm gonna I'm gonna be able to play
things like Keith oh well probably well
that's a poor blundered upon I think
that this b5 move was a no calculation
Hikaru move yeah but it's also a very
kind of no calculation at carlo's like
before and switching everything you Thor
file but the script yeah I can act like
my a5 pond was a sacrifice right yeah
yeah I think he's still he's trying to
keep the time like he's ahead on locked
it to maintain that you maintain that
Bluff so but yeah he I mean b3 okay it's
not an impressive pond but it's a pond
yep but I don't think nak is too
concerned here no the same pond is about
as bad as an extra pond comes I think
the real thing to worry about is white
space advantage on the Kings side
ninety-three and f4 white switches to
the the double defile this could be
where white
finds his playin and that's what Mac
seems preparing to do he wants to punch
up fourth room
it's almost though as if the game would
go the same way whether there was a pawn
on a 5-4 black or not did Weston yeah
because that's why I couldn't be playing
a four right yeah sure yeah let's say um
but you know the way it is right now
black is not really the one that plays
f5 but he's he's sort of deterred white
for the moment with that for he did the
stutter step f3 but he's finally opened
it up don't let that night get to e5
yeah this is his you know this is his
idea Queen B 2 is very strong and it's
hard to move the King away because
there's lots of noises yeah
Queen Queen d2 very strong by the way
yeah
the next scene is kind of 96 looks very
good he seems pretty happy you happy
with this position here yeah yep so what
happens after night I take she said it
well Knight g6 just King takes
I think 96 looks like the only way to
try something but you get into this
position where after let's say f e6 rook
f6 work 8 - I know there's rook F 7
well I was gonna say you don't have to
do anything in sakaram necessarily
because your work is already guarding
the second rank a 7th rank but right but
I think Maxime taking the right approach
anyway just build up on the pressure
don't don't look there was some serious
moves coming there like if night for
there was a 96 late nineties anyway
takes he's why does he have to play e5
here I'm surprised he didn't play e5
ooh he's getting the ladies off maxime
justice I would say that he I think he
took me back instinctively but I think
he should have maybe consider whether it
was the right thing to allow here now
his King on h3 but there's no checks and
rook F seven is serious so it
what rook Eastbrook EE 7 and then rook
g7 well I was gonna say rookie e7 rook
f8 right
yeah and then rugby sevens or even
rookie I've blocking the Queen and
threatening rook h5 that's a
good-looking one
yeah actually again it's gonna be funny
to see who ends up getting themselves
made it here so rookie five rookie five
even right away bretons rookie wife know
exactly that's what I wanted to do right
away I like to look at that okay he did
he was still going for something they
want a king g6 King age five yeah
interesting of a passive move rookie six
yeah but maxime has to be very satisfied
with the move g5 like ivory key five
look like a really serious like there's
just like weird tactics potentially here
like okay just to show something crazy
if rook f7 and black blundered King h8
then rookie two would be winning on the
spot Queen takes c2 Brooke takes he gave
mate yes
so takes Queen h7 right and exactly if
the Queen takes each you then King h7 so
sort of a double double pin emote but um
but after check black can play King g8
and I don't think Accardo has a win so
right kingi yeah this there's rook f8 in
that position as well to deal with but
he's done what I think makes a lot of
sense he just faced them of rook a six
so that rook just took itself off the
seventh ring not to do a completely
defensive thing and if you trade Queens
it's set up for role on the a file and
guarding d6 if you keep the Queen's on
it exposes how I didn't write oh just
resign there then was it there's no way
to stop
rook f7 and 85 I'm gonna be back for one
sec I just have to get the front door go
for it nobody knocks on the door in real
time and we're like what not everyone is
watching this show okay but backing up
it would be would be very interesting
you know where that game went wrong for
Hikaru but what matters is we are still
engaged in a in a super close matched of
deadlock match and still a battle of
just opening attrition here neither
neither side wants to blink their
both believe in the positions they've
been playing to this point and they're
not going to change their ideas this is
amazing amazing that this match has been
so back and forth we are getting what we
asked for and in 10 games that Hikaru
Nakamura has been white we have had 10
Grunfeld so if you're keeping score at
home get off your baseball scorecard and
mark that down need to be one this is
gonna be a different approach than a car
where he's gotten his best positions
here is white it's often been with the
Queen on f3 and and things happening
early and often on the F file so every
time I see this particular approach
happen makes me feel like Hikaru is not
getting the best of his variations but
he's up significantly on time here maybe
that'll help he 5 in d6 was this was an
approach we saw instead of trying to be
aggressive on the FI lure obvious
advantages are that you block the Bishop
from d4 which okay Maxime is gonna try
to change a Queen b6 jackin do I have
east six what in the world loading hello
come on say hello to the e pawns Eddie
the Eagle is back in town
great movie great movie yeah great story
d7 and eat okay you can't play you seven
right away but I mean I just you know
I'm I'm probably getting a little too
excited glad I'm not on camera about
those points no I mean this is uh he did
some work right in this in this opening
that clearly knowing that he's played
when you were gone I was highlighting
just how quickly he's now played since
he's had this position ten of ten games
his white yeah this is the best that
this opening has looked yeah along with
that game where he opened the F file
early this is crushing this is just the
demolition have five is on the cards
dish the mission to t4 but Bishop f2
yeah we have this this is on pace and
and this is the kind of thing that my
client who's been helping you and I
behind the scenes shoutout to our boy
just Mike he's been helping us but this
is honest feels on pace to have some of
the most games played in speech Chess
Championship history Michael
probably remind me of what that record
is I think it's I think it was Magnus's
match versus so yeah that one was quick
as well it but you know what it is
it has to do with them playing the same
openings on your right yeah they're
playing the faster and faster yeah so
not much but now we're starting to see a
little bit of mixing it up here this is
the most open we've seen of the the
gioco italian games we've had so far yes
Mike confirming that I was correct about
my Magnus versus so match and he said
nobody has actually come close to that
match and it was because as Wesley for
those who watched that last year as
mostly kind of went on tilt he was
resigning a lot of games early and
Magnus just just can't stop won't stop
it was 37 games yeah he sensed the the
weakness and he just jumped on it and
that's not at all how this one is
because as you can see the score is
actually very very close yep
impressive that you still see so many
news okay well now back to a one game
lead for Hikaru and on the black side of
a joke oh where he's found himself
almost every game is black but yes I
mean this isn't this isn't the close
centre we saw last game where Maxime got
the Knight to f5 but I I feel like
white's chances are better here than
last game and maybe maybe I'm wrong but
I guess I just like the e-file pressure
and I like that I can still put a pony
on f5 where you can't play g6 without a
g6 falling right get my right to like
right here
teach me I'm on teach me teach well
where my impressive knowledge of this
opening comes from watching it smash to
the dark Oh yours is mine both along
with the Grunfeld right I'm going off
I'm going off the match but from from
what we've seen so far it's always been
that there's been a little bit of an
imbalance sometimes we'll see black with
the queenside majority sometimes we'll
see why it in this opening what what I
see right now definitely looks like well
right before this hoop seem to be
favoring white just because you have the
type of position where there's one
weakness and and you're the guy
attacking it but what we just saw there
he's not he's five or very direct
approach I was completely on board with
you about liking white as we said and
because of the main weakness was he
fight but Hikaru somehow steals that c4
pawn and doesn't think his queen is
gonna get trapped I wonder if Maxine he
thought he needed weakness is very very
impressive I was gonna say I wonder if
Maxine thought he was gonna get like 90
to 91 and and uh but no okay I mean the
the endgame is just extremely good for
for black if not completely winning so I
don't think it's even an option to play
them if I queen takes c3 and he doesn't
yep indeed slides the Queen de to
threats of rook to e8
f7 would fall probably Maxine plays
queen c6 here stopping before right
sorry sorry
hey Carlo please I'm sorry it was no he
plays Knight f6 and likes the Queen
active where she is threats on b4 maybe
even a three and Queen B 2 is a way that
yeah a3 just looks like a very nice move
yeah especially now I would play a 3 a 3
does he want to go to the pure endgame
with like rook c2 here cuz he can force
it if the Queen song no he threatens
rook e1 which is also pretty irritating
and in fact that move unpinned the rook
from the Queen on c3 so exactly dual
purpose movement Nakuru the cargo grabs
the a pawn and we got apples on a1 how
you like them apples
what do you think about rook e8 as a
weird move jacking the exchange am on
Hambleton style oh I think you can even
play King h7 I don't think it works but
I do like it probably doesn't
I do like tactics from Amman Hamilton
you know I just love saying your name
it's taking all I have not too much now
with the a yes the play teenage 7 right
this is what I wanted at least maybe
yeah this is what I wanted it's open my
black is black is winning and indeed
Joshua Chamberlain will not strike does
anybody else ever seeing you your name
and song his name is Aman Hamilton or is
that just a me thing no well you might
not just be a you thing but there could
be some some closeted singers who
haven't come ugly nerves you know yeah
well they haven't made themselves known
on Hamilton on Broadway with lin-manuel
Miranda's coming we got to make your
life a little more interesting yes the
sporadic hair dyeing just doesn't cut it
doesn't alright we're back to that super
aggressive approach we saw but Maxine
wasn't successful when the Queen came to
h4 and got chased around so here
different approach I I'm more skeptical
of this approach for Maxine because now
when we take on d4 I don't even know if
I have to take me five perhaps I'll play
a three first I don't know I I'm
skeptical of blacks over extension of
the Kings side and willingly giving me
the two Center pawns here I don't think
black is getting any kind of attack but
and in fact I really like this move
honestly because the car was calling his
bluff he's probably gonna just take open
the King d4 is gonna fall anyway and a
pawn is a pawn right yeah that I mean
this is it looks offhand like it could
be a pretty dangerous attack but once
again we're gonna see black just the
pawns are disappearing and you know seen
a car down the exchange in this type of
position many times so far so you know
that he's for example comfortable
playing with like like that Wow
speed the speed of which Accardo is now
starting to play these gun fields and
finally starting to get better positions
it feels like his stubbornness and
whatever the preparation choice that he
had to play this grünfeld mind is
started to pay off his white right you
feel the same time yeah I think I feel
the exact same way he's really
comfortable here and we've seen these
two connected eeeh deep Khan's roll up
the board like two games in a row here
with white
that's why they're getting so many games
in Danny because they're playing so fast
like the opening phase doesn't existing
just disappeared from the match or the
resident again like people are resigning
before I'm even sure why and well it was
King g8 Bishop c4 I think right I'll go
back to I mean I know that Wright was
like the you know Canadian looking down
on me it's okay but let's go look well
the thing is that these guys are playing
moves and then I'm like processing that
presents yeah King g8 Bishop c4 and I
think it was just I'm going to do Knight
I'm totally teasing and I'm with you it
feels like they're uh they're just
really they're very aware I think an
experience in the format and I think
they know that you know losing time on
the overall match clock one of the
things that makes the format unique
these guys are like we keep saying it
they're they're as old pro and this
format as anybody right I think magazine
is just not gonna and he's not gonna
waste five minutes on the clock
defending lost positions against a card
oh yeah yeah but whether he's gonna
waste time or not we do have our first
Viet right it's the first three-game
lead in the match now that's true okay
that's true and I think it's been very
clear in the second portion here the
three-minute compared to the five minute
in a five minute black was winning
almost all the green fields and somehow
even coming up better in the Italian
games but in this portion white is we
almost every single game an Takara's
hair blowing in the wind to the disco
club he apparently has just entered in
with his webcam and you really get your
diamond membership with a Photoshop
contest on Twitter that is a we're about
to start hearing the BG's and John
Travolta comes out in skinny jeans he
his half of his face has disappeared he
still got like I'm gonna go to a scene
with just you and I on camera right now
I mean I don't know that I can take much
more of this oh my god he needs to put
those glasses back but the glasses back
on
Oh put the glasses back on then I'll
keep it on oh good okay just just the
just the change and and yeah
and we we're back to a normal camera so
nothing nothing super special anymore
fair
well while that was happening I can say
was arguably more exciting than this
game because this is probably the most
like just overall draw game we've seen
yeah
after all right they're gonna agree
after our first three-game winning
streak we have our first snoozefest yeah
which is I mean in some ways you want to
stabilize after after that if it was
better off sure it's gonna be Maxine
he's got the open file whatever but it's
not it's not a big deal here depending
on what happens in bullet Mike Klein
feels that did this match could be on
pace the challenge a lady f5 legendary
37 games played by Magnus Carlsen and
Wesley so last year 37 Wow okay this
this game it would be the kind of thing
that would happen if they take another
quick draw here and just say alright
we're done
you know but I don't think we're gonna
get that who was that f5 King takes g5
rook takes h3 he was not good for her
and BL because white gets I don't know I
thought of oh now he goes for it I
wonder if he could have done it less
move because taking on f5 wasn't an
option anyway due to the rook actually
being hanging there so right but okay
we're gonna find out Maxime will win the
g6 pawned the problem is the a pawn
would have been hanging okay for that so
you play b6 and then I he was probably
planning to do it if if it still existed
yeah
hey maybe we were wrong maybe a boring
finish is not what we have in store
Maxime securing this Jeep on and
McCarter doesn't have a pass or to
compete with it he may have to sacrifice
III did you get the B to pawn what do
you think yeah it looks like that's on
the on the cards but once you take me to
the issue I have is that in order to get
a real passer yeah you always have to do
b3 - yeah well I think that's why he
carro plays b5 is there maybe ideas
where you get this pawn to a4 and at
some point find yourself winning B to
but but Maxime is definitely leading the
race with this cheap one although it's
funny now white isn't sort of a Zuke's
one you never can step away the king
from the g6 square without something
like king of five being a problem yeah I
think he understood that yes this upon
looks very dangerous I'm not sure I
agree with this vibe next yeah this is a
this is a real problem we are about to
see this this has to be wrong got to see
our first three game lead of the match
turned into our first four game lead of
the magic ro is Stella got her groove
back come on
so if I play E - Ricky one forest King
e6 and then I think black is well I'm
concerned because I have it have to
epoch yeah so if I get you to sack for
one of them another one that's Goro
bringing us back to the disco club baby
Kenny for and just King East Union
hoochie - a month point everybody is
let's say we're in a situation where
black has to give up the road for the
pawn is white he's just dead because Y
can't return the favor if white gives up
his rook for the pawn black has another
one behind it and indeed Oh
Maxime just resigned he's not gonna
spend any more time on that for Maxime
to lose that in game it's very poor very
poor Carlo has all smiles just got a
message gave us a quick it karo number
seven checking theory a quick while
tokoro sighting but goes back to his
normal facial expression we appreciate
that well what was that
is laughing yeah I don't know I think
yeah my guess is he had a friend tell
him something or Accardo it lives in a
lot of different chat rooms I've been
I've been watching him play bullet
matches where he's you know one of those
epic four hours four hours in he's
dominating Jakob I don't know 87 to 1 or
something like that right you've been
there right I've been there he's a big R
and and he's simultaneously chatting
with me on skype well just like you know
and he did what I'm assuming he was
trying to do since the start of the
match he he broken yeah he broke the
grin fell yeah he did he broke the grin
fight he he caused Maxine just wit maxi
of all people to switch his opening and
I think that's already like winning the
mattress yeah it's a it's a huge sign
that the writing might be on the wall I
mean this this feels like vaccine has
been toe-to-toe with him by me okay
doesn't feel that way the match was just
tied nine to nine for those of you who
may just be joining us so that's now 13
to 9 it we're not exaggerating to say
it's been a close match but but yeah
like I said Stella seems to have found
her groove Taye Diggs showed up they
look madly in love and Hikaru is back on
winning streaks oh man this is this is a
very good move as well 95 there's this
Bishop b7 shot yep
in about in every position intending
well I mean now this this is not good
pressure on b7 the bishop here now
belongs to white even just simple
warrant I was gonna say wrecker oka oh I
was testing him this year if one is
needed or or Queen b5 the endgame as
well a game has a nice cute little
thread in some positions you might just
take on c6 and double the C pawns and
take a seven with a knife so I supposed
he's really going for to open things up
yeah
can I get away with Bishop seasick I
wanted it you know I wanted irony
pretty called it it's not going for
other thing is what white is gonna be
better by so many ways here that he's
probably trying to minimize the risk
because the bishop on g2 is very good
he's got the two bishops he's got the F
4045 pretty standard expansion of his
punching yep and this is one of those
positions where the bishop pair can can
really turn very dominant very quickly
Maxime doing his best to get the D file
which is one way to compensate but gonna
be very hard decision well you can
always play rook d1 yes simplifying
gonna be very hard for the Knights to
compete with the bishops if what Amon
said comes true if the F and E pawns get
rolling and the position remains open
yeah we're gonna tear up d1 nice little
tactic in terms I'm sure it's incredibly
meaningful but it'll change the
structure take on c3 Intermezzo and the
main thing is if he can get the Knight
to c4 and maybe set up some sort of hold
where this bishop won't see one doesn't
get developed and right as I say that a
car was gonna fix that problem with you
for ya and he's going nuts hey Carlos in
the disco room give me give me a car oh
in a disco ball maybe John Travolta's
there and I don't know I'm the Oprah of
diamond memberships today I want to give
them away gimme gimme my Photoshop what
is he what is he listening to I love
when a car goes nuts I think I think
he's singing as well right
you can't exactly see his lips ah hey
car number 14
well amidst all this his position has
gotten much worse so the dancing aside
he at least it's opposite bishop so we
can be sure that the most that's gonna
happen here is nvl is gonna like waste a
bunch of time on the clock and still not
win right know it and I guess from a
match point of view you're you're right
that not a lot at stake here for hikaru
unless he starts off on a on the wrong
foot and bullet and
and uh you know breathes breeds
confidence back into his opponent then
you see Maxime offered to draw and that
Gus said no okay now they said yes
because it's like that's the worst worst
position on the end or Maxime it's like
you're up upon but it's a dead draw and
you're just wasting your own time and
we've had a few of those where are our
competitors openly admitted afterwards
that they you know we're very aware of
the match strategy it the sec formats
different that you're competing against
this clock counting down and magnus
admitted it that he you know played a
position way longer and grishnak
admitted it and i think you know there's
nothing that's that's that's
gamesmanship that's being aware of what
you're up against right so i wouldn't
have got him playing it out but i think
in this case a karo you know is just
happy to play more chess i i don't see
why that's an issue probably the most
notable games i mean every sport has it
soccer actually doesn't have it as bad
as others right football is the most
american football has yeah has best
example i mean they're just taking these
spiking the ball anything at waist
o'clock basketball they're intentionally
fouling right and nobody blinks and i
for for that so i don't really have any
issue with that it's always frustrating
to be on the receiving end of that
treatment but i I don't have the problem
within myself well under four minutes
now remain very likely unless we see a
blunder that you are watching the last
three minute game of today's match thank
you to all almost nine thousand of you
we've had at at our peak here today and
this has been this has been a super
instructive exciting match and we'll see
if Maxine can and get a little momentum
swinging his way with the white pieces
here before the bullet starts cuz yeah I
think he's gonna need it
yep he's gonna need at least a better
game cuz we saw it still affect him when
he took a terrible terrible loss from
the five-minute section into the three
minutes we saw the next game in the
three-minute was was also very bad very
quick very slow it doesn't need to win
but he just needs to have a reasonable
game and then get set for bullet where I
think
be the first to admit that he's a fare
underdog right so it's even more reason
that he needs to look at this
calculation from mcaro this e3 pawn sack
was designed specifically around this
idea that the Queen can swing and
compensation now with this e3 pawn being
under attack but more than compensation
Knight takes III followed by rook takes
e4
oh yes Hollywood he's looking across up
that was a car number 9 there is Bishop
f2 at the end of that line so he's gonna
oh noes but that was her car number 9
that's usually when he's putting the
game away Brooke takes he won his check
yes yeah kake's hey what do you take do
you take on an f1 yeah oh man
okay maxime gonna do everything you can
but since bishop he won't check and then
take a1 if you really want to play this
- Brooks for the Queen I'm not sure that
you do but maybe you do I don't know
yeah you might be like just settle in -
okay no he wants it he's going for it
all right
yeah here we go he's all in here he's
feeling confident
so queen b7 or Queen c7 I think it's
gonna be rook e8 and he wants rookie
three fault that back - do you
play h5 here is that annoying Rucker
rovco means castles in Russian bread the
colour 23h five threats of rookie three
are coming the king is in a bit of a
meeting net the main things you got to
watch out for things like Bishop on g1
moving and suddenly rook h1 brings me a
cold bishop okay it doesn't work but if
you can move the bishop and get rookie
three check with Bishop e3 then rotation
one might be made yeah so if he's gonna
play GG three no okay he said he was
relying on checks there yeah to get him
out of that but black always seems to
have a resource rook f1 in the position
to cover f7 and then let him focus on
whatever checkmate pattern he's trying
to achieve so Queen f6 stops work f1
it's not gonna be a drill
yeah it looks like they might just have
a tickle here f7 is too weak and I'm not
sure what the official word is yet from
our judge behind the scenes Manning the
the actual game timer in case we ever
have photo finishes is this the last
game or do or if they finish quickly
will they get another one
well MDL I think I think he Carlo is
very aware he Caro is actually well MDL
salon who can choose the draw doesn't he
want another game well I think I think
that's why he Cara was sitting here
pausing so hey Cara was the one who can
make sure he doesn't get another one in
fact I just saw hit karo glance yeah
she's looking at the clock and I think I
think Acorah saw that our official judge
lets them know with every gain how much
time is left and I think Accardo knew
that he was right there and look at that
gamesmanship Wow hey cor Nakamura no he
didn't know he starts we've aborted the
game we will officially let the players
know that that it's time for the break
Issachar oh and the disc of dance can
check how did you not know he agreed
rate after it was beautiful I think I
think he was waiting for the the
official word e again he car was a pro
he knows that it's it's Pete actually
our senior editor and Events Manager who
helps us with that so I think he knew he
knew that the game would be aborted but
what I don't know is whether we're gonna
have a close finish it's gonna take
Maxime pulling some stuff together a
bond
you're his coach you're in his corner
you're telling him don't dye your hair
and what else well he's grown a nice a
nice handsome beard so he's he's got
that going for him but he he needs to
sort of loosen up that's it feels very
rigid he's going for the same openings
all the time the same bad things are
happening and I find Nakamura despite
winning the games to be more adaptive
than MVL who's on the worse end so in
bullet you're gonna get the same disco
Hikaru very confident right and Ola it's
going to be even more
difficult to deal with that cargo who's
playing so well the last couple games so
you really need to stick that head
underwater and come back fresh all right
you heard it from coach I'm on here
first and and you did give him advice
about hairstyling but again he's got the
beard so that's all he really needs and
we'll see if Maxine fashion girl can
pull it together all of you will be here
in about two minutes when we come back
because I know where you are I know
where you live and you don't want to
leave and leave us behind so come on
I'll be right back with the final
segment of the quarter of the final
quarterfinals match 14 to 10 it is as we
head into the final section of today's
match well you won't use the word
portion again apparently I use the word
portions a lot but in this final portion
Maxine might need some potion if he's
gonna if he's gonna do something magical
hey Cara Nakamura known as the best
bullet player one of the best in history
for a reason and you heard him aunt
advice for all all those of you been
with us the players are ready and I
believe really we don't need much more
much more ado benta than to do it let's
let's do it yeah
getting into the bullet portion which as
everyone knows who watches these speed
chess championships is one plus one so
you still do have that implement there
which is quite a big deal I would say
for everybody facing cacar oh that
that's like a safety net if this was
regular bullet I think you car would be
a much bigger favorite on the ground
Phil continues but now we see Maxime
change it up with move I believe that
was moved eight castles is what made the
difference allowing white to play d5 but
but a carro playing like he knew this
might be something Maxime tried and
still as a peasant advantage on the
clock more time that he started with
this already looks fantastic for the car
h6 is hanging okay h6 is hanging pretty
sure yeah X is hanging
and he goes for it ooh Knight takes d5
love that move I don't care if it works
good job
neither does NACA though he feels like
I'm gonna be anything this is uh takes
takes takes mate nakamura style now if
this playing really fast right now
almost too fast like I would say
somewhere around the night 65 to now
yeah maybe Aires a lot of things yes
you know you might regret that but uh
well blacks position looks it you know
for a reasonable Bishop e6 now yes
governor 548 blacks actually looking
fantastic
something went astray perhaps he's not
up upon which I thought initially
because that H pun is missing from
blacks perspective but the bish money to
is not convincing 95 not a big deal I
saw five range moved to have to play is
he gonna take that into if I just trying
to take four so Queen g5 though and
Queenie a certain things have switched
around
id3 doesn't win the exchange that or
does because of rook h7 okay
I think I miss Bishop takes c4 some yeah
he could at least take aged six take c1
take h5 he's probably bit better but
maybe there's even a better line than
that he goes for it though I think white
is oh wow 25 he wants to take aged five
and keep an attack going with the ladies
on the board I like it that that makes a
lot of sense yep we actually see naka
down on time for the again a rare
sighting well it's even more rare and
bullet that's the thing he's just so so
fast
kingi to and we're gonna see okay we're
gonna see I we were gonna see Queen III
even try to get the Queen's off the
board but look at him watch to d3 like
Queen a 3.86 junk and after King II to
Queen d2 check the King goes to f4 I
don't know oof it's getting messy um so
what Queen f4 maybe there although you
have to be careful Queen takes f6 cuz
that might be
yeah we need five a nice a nice try
though because now maxxium is able to
get the Queen's off the board and not
lose the f6 pawn yeah but this is I
think rook takes f3 yeah I was gonna say
he gets it in time man and ladies and
gentlemen the first match the first game
of the bullet section goes to my breasts
I'm impressed
that's the turnaround I think I think
he'd put his head under cold water there
yeah that's uh that's what maxime knees
right you got to get got to get as many
wins in a row as you can okay obviously
but to start the section with that
victory is is a big practical win these
guys know so much theory here this is
bullet and we've got hit Cairo at like a
minute and eight seconds yep it's kind
of a funny opening to be playable at the
Berlin yeah well no they're just playing
getting bullet but playing you know
whatever you want to call it home
cooking playing like playing high-level
Berlin stuff yeah okay you're you're a
little overqualified for the job here
yeah exactly
King g3 I mean White has the more
flexible position but black has the
better looking everything strike for a3
will fall night to be fine there is no
c4 work that's that's a little we're
gonna say you could take the bishop on
e6 and play c4 just to get a seven but
don't know how I don't create that yeah
the knight would have come to d4 I guess
and there was 90s alright okay so maxi
will probably take on e7 Nexus next
chance he gets he he can take a 7 but it
came at the cost of like six pours
falling no I don't see any reason not to
take it neither does it karo broke a to
Jack this King bite it and it's end
itself in a weird mate he's I'm
recycling the knight again you have to
be careful not to lose that bishop yeah
yeah you can't play rookie choucas king
of four and we have Forks well we have
king f4 anyway so that's actually
something you can see yeah
so maybe yeah maybe he needs to play 90
of one first anyway back up the bishop
and
things are getting a little weird though
because f7 could be could be fine the
reason I have sevens okay is because it
broke after two at the mill right we're
just keeping a minute but okay Brooke c7
you're threatening rookie seven and
Knight f7 looks pretty good Brooke g2
threatens rookie four watch out can the
93 mate ISA Mixon he was desperate to
get out of the net so weird I would play
I would play maybe c5 some type of movie
like look at the knight and Bishop
working so well together here it's like
the knight and Bishop mate speaking of
which watch out for a nice seafood e8
yeah I would play c5 yeah give me some
space I know I got like a ton of extra
pawns Lisa it looks like a car should
have enough to get this one as long as
he can avoid either perpetual Zoar or
weird bishop mates but like I said this
is like a knight and Bishop Clinic as
far as how they're coordinating together
and you know yeah Eugene c3 is safe
though you see three barely safe for now
for the moment but now it's history you
move Bishop before check I anticipated
but both people could be like checking
out I don't know who's that's what I was
saying is that the way they're
coordinating is like a conic why not
rook check this foots kind of good does
rookie four at the end of everything
so rook check he's behind it I think
he's trying to use this time to see make
sure he doesn't miss a chance for mate
oh man what a weird weird weird game
yeah if the bishop comes before guarding
b700
[Music]
this this has shifted now that the black
king is safer than the white team yeah
I'd have five checks a threat what he
wants to simplify I guess make sure he's
not gonna lose he Cardos just sort of
settles on the draw I'm surprised that
like you are but yeah and Maxime is
gonna make sure that the game can't last
too much longer get the pieces off the
board wait 13 seconds why not
there he is playing match strategy
Hikaru why hide the don't forget to take
it though
yeah he trades and hey Maxime won the
first game of the bullet if you happen
to have just joined us so this is this
is not gonna be one of those runaway
trains for hikaru at this point given
that Maxime is one and a half out of the
first two games but but if hey car was
in a position where he can just start
milking the clock a month as you said it
you made your basketball reference
that's the equivalent of you know
working working the the shot clock when
you're up on up on the score wall right
that that there's too much camaraderie
in chess that Bishop endgame could have
been played for fifteen minutes for
example yeah if your car really wanted
to because do you think about that what
do you think about because you get plus
one second and you get 50 moves that's a
long time I think within within you know
reasonable opportunities to extend games
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it from an ethical or whatever
perspective but okay I it would be a
little weird to play on that much but we
have seen it we saw again I think we saw
Magnus play a king and rook ending okay
I don't remember um we've seen it before
right and the thing is though in time
which was with an increment you almost
never see it because they would they
would flag each other ruthlessly don't
get us wrong right if it was sudden
death and they would they wouldn't lose
any sleep over it but an increment
they're kind of like uh you know there's
no yeah there's no flagging yeah there's
no flag though they're the thrill of the
kill is gone yeah okay so hey Carl uh
we're getting our first and it's got a
good little two bishop set up I would
say yeah and I was saying we're getting
our first set of unique positions we've
had in a while and and no more grünfeld
theory yeah you'll be hard-pressed to
get these anyone to repeat things that
much you lose all your inhibitions when
you play bullet I think that's the body
on all your inhibitions go out the
window
no if I if I need you to loan me some
money you're saying there's gotta let
you pull you beat me a bullet that's
that's yes did it you did adopt me so
technically I could use a few bucks from
my dad well you get you getting
allowance all right
rook takes a 7 and D sevens coming I
think I think a carro is getting himself
in a good position again Bishop e5 also
very strong if this night comes to the
square we've got
chemos on the loose 95 he wants rook d4
followed by Queen d6 I just use some
really cool colors though apologies
rookie for Queen D we define a car is
still in the driver's seat though jokes
aside no he definitely is we can come to
b7 with check am I crazy
I think it wins a media not crazy just
winning just winning not crazy just
winning will you remind everybody that
you said that not crazy just winning
alright it's over
hey Carl gets a victory here and he's
he's gonna move this match back to a
four-game lead he's gonna resign in his
own inch was as he should yeah it's uh
you're not out of that mathematical
territory yet right as we switch over to
our scoreboard view and we have we have
19 and a half minutes left roughly on
the clock keep an eye on our patience I
think it's probably it's still in the
realm of possibility maybe to reach this
this 30 37 games or so yeah when they
start playing long games like that and n
games I think that's gonna hurt that's
gonna hurt if they're if they mutual
Wow but when you yep when you wonder and
now you have your first Viking lead of
the match in new car oh is she okay that
was the quickest game
I saw chess bait mentioned that maybe
he's singing ABBA so he's definitely
definitely the dancing queen when he
gets rolling and car we're not afraid of
roll with it and viola has gotten
crushed in two games that at least I can
remember this this match absolutely
crushed yep and here this looks in
general one rule is that when you play
Bishop g4 in these London or like
exchange slop types of structures and
you don't get to take a knight it's not
fully bad side beat 94
they'd have to play nine games in the
next 19 minutes if we're if we're about
to witness oh this is straw
this is terrible opposite Bishop
position down upon the Carl could
literally take five of us off the game
clock with this game not oh my god this
is the worst situation he puts a rook on
the C file plus he can still lose right
or maybe he will like that that's the
worst part about it is that it's worse
Oh No yep yeah this is very bad
yeah it's not even this that Hikaru is
playing for the time right he's he's no
he's the only one who didn't win this
position yeah no he's trying to win no
question about it but the nice thing is
that while he's trying to win he's also
accomplishing his at his goal of wasting
time as well have foreign yeah well he
carved and he did find himself at some
point in this match and I think that one
of the things were definitely gonna ask
him afterwards and hey who knows what's
gonna happen in the next 17 minutes but
if he goes on to to win at this point I
wonder if there was if what some of your
some of your theories were corrected
Hikaru check on the line was this
preparation did he feel more confident
coming back from the five-minute break
right yeah no I would love to know so we
will definitely ask those questions in
the post match interview so make sure
you stick around for that everybody okay
hope to see eight I thought maybe he
would play no he wants to bring the rook
to this area with tempo I don't think
that knack is too concerned about
playing the best moves here no and I but
I love this idea anyway he forced us to
sort of give ground d5 you're accenting
the e5 and then infiltrate it I really
wanted to just swing the rotate to and
give up the pawn but you could have
taken with check and that would have
prevented me from getting in but here
comes the rook in Bishop f4 to give the
check right threatening roof e6 so that
there's no roof d6
what did she's seven very nice
threatening rook g5 now now maybe Bishop
c5 is a threat to take h5
so blacks gonna put the bishop on f3 and
say yeah good night Lee fine good
afternoon good evening and good night
you can't beat me anymore Eric um but at
the same time the position can be played
forever and now very nice so that's yeah
that's how you draw defensive technique
they're getting the rooks off the board
you could even bring the King now to g2
and Hikaru really has no progress I'm
just gonna say that if NACA had played
that last bishop bang game for 50 moves
and if he plays this one for 50 moves by
the way he can throw in like an f3 I'm
just saying that's that's like a lot of
time lot of time yep he's doing it this
time is he well look at him his hair is
blowing in the wind we a free spirit
right how do you I wonder how this makes
butch chat feel twitch chat feelings let
yourself be known chest TV chat feelings
watching Tampa chests give advice for
the last hour and a half one yeah I mean
how do people feel about this in a lot
of other sports it's it's very okay and
very part of the game and both sides do
it sort of unnecessary roughness
unsportsmanlike contact or contact or
good gamesmanship up for debate right
he's taking a good amount of time off
the clock yep well you know it's
insurance right he's getting enough time
off the clock to make sure that should
he you know start joking on a sandwich
and have to deal with that for 10
minutes he's not gonna lose the match
right I guess cuz he can let his time
run down after he's built it up the +1
really like doubles the efficiency of
this strategy right well I guess the
argument would be that the I don't think
it's the best for your chess to do this
strategy and so if this were a close
match and someone did that and they were
only by a game or two like it probably
wouldn't be the best thing for their
chest right so the argument is that
they're doing it in a position where
they've earned a 5 or 6 game lead and so
if you're in that
in position well you know but yeah it
would be like if it was tied 100 100 and
basketball and then you intentionally
fouled what he do it it wouldn't make a
lot of sense right yeah that's
definitely true yeah I think that this
naturally causes everybody to be Pro MVL
right like you know a little bit of like
wait I mean at this point you're kind of
routing anyway for the underdog because
you can't not given that they're down by
five games and unless you're just like
your trusty Pat again where does this I
don't know me this is a really bad
position I mean you're not better
I mean you maybe you're barely better
but that's even worse so you think that
you should play it on but realistically
you're not gonna beat NACA here you're
gonna waste so much time on the clock I
think this is terrible well I think if
you're Maxime to the next time you get
to play hey Cara win this format which
at this point they seem to get paired
every year in the quarterfinals okay you
would say maybe a car was saying he's a
little bit afraid of Maxine maybe he
actually does think Maxine is capable of
a comeback and respects that so you know
you take what you can it's a mini win to
say well you know I got to put myself in
a better spot in these bullet-time
controls where I have no chance to beat
Nakamura which is true and after Rick f1
is I mean he lost the house on the
queenside here a lot of Queen b7 Queen
takes a 7 and sometimes I think that my
pawn is defended because I've got two
pieces on the seventh but it's like this
x-ray where of course you're you hide
your queen behind your own rook and you
can just grab all these pawns he self
upon here yep again is this giving him
false hope like he's gonna try to win
now and waste even more time who nobody
gave up the pawn on purpose yeah I I
would like to think that he's that good
but I'm not sure about that he might be
I you know I wouldn't put a pastor
because this is so hard to win that rook
just goes to d2 you have all the
pressure on f2 you can collect b-tree
whenever you want yeah it's just you're
frustrating the guy he's not gonna win
it's really really tough situation at
the end for the MVL corner there yes
these games he's not getting big
advantages but he's getting something
and he car is not even agreeing to a
draw from a worse position
well well hikaru willingly takes the
lease off and lay it on baby play it on
yes Brook takes pawn of course you have
to but yeah yeah diamond take your sweet
time oh this could be another he didn't
do it no the other he really needs to I
think he like I said I think acara was
doing the smart thing I think it's easy
it's all it's our job as media
commentators and fans to kind of give
our opinion but you know I think from a
removed perspective he's being smart and
okay well he would all be feels a little
more confident now that there's only ten
minutes left let me deposit a theory to
you
hey so I'm the bank is open baby deposit
away so you're you're talking to your
middle school and you got your crush and
you're texting her and you text her my
son is doing this probably as we speak
so I'm right there with you
yep okay so you text her and you're like
listen I you know I really like you do
you like me right
and then wait for a response and then if
the response is bad like last dude my
friend was on my phone oh man sorry yeah
but you just you want to see what the
response is but then it's exposed then
you know what kind of person you know
you know what the response rate you know
the situation is neck has already told
us what kind of person he is he's a
flagger himself as that so own it and
just keep doing it I don't understand
how you do that once and then just be
like yeah it was Andy just by the way
while we were on our middle school
tangent which you have no idea funny
that is and how realistic that is for me
right now
Picaro just absolutely obliterated
Maxine yeah he just cried that was okay
so you know yeah you're right I mean
it's I don't think there's any any shame
in saying that we know that hit carro
along with any any you know they old
they all do it to each other and flag
and those who follow those those chats
and relationships closely know how guys
like hikaru and narrow disky feel about
each other after they do it to each
other right right or how narrow discs he
breaks his own hand when he's frustrated
so yeah you're right he's already
exposed himself and why go back now
right yep yeah but she went
crush the game so I think he he's just
in the zone right now he's got a very
comfortable six-game lead and when you
think about six bullet ins that's more
than the time on the clock right that
and it's not like he's gonna lose six in
a row so you think both statistically
and just according to everything we know
about Nakamura that he's got this in the
bag
yep well uh it'll definitely be
interesting to talk to the players
afterwards I think Maxine would say he
really felt like he was in the match and
and clearly a couple games got away from
him and and then he couldn't stop the
bleeding but we'll definitely be asking
some opening specific questions for
those stronger maybe more experienced
players who were kind of curious on the
preparation and approach they had yeah
we got to two main openings to quiz the
Napoli yeah
we've been getting opposite bishops a
lot and I understand that at this point
probably doesn't matter that much to
Maxime
but yeah he's oh this is really what's
about to happen well because there's a
to and rookie five all gone wrong it's
not so bad maybe we overreacted it was a
nice tactic I don't know if he executed
it in the proper order or if it even
should have been executed at all right
but again you're like you're up one pond
this by the way probably is winning so
this is his best chance to you in here
go Maxime the hype is real hype is real
this may be our last match where I get a
chance to justifiably spam the emotes so
I will we're not all been Feingold where
we root for somebody who's not even in
the match hashtag go Wesley Michaelis
known as both both an in the closet and
out of the closet Wesley so super fans
so and but at least Wesley's in the
tournament right it's not as true
cheering him on for his next night
[Music]
parsley just did it was it yeah just on
Tuesday
they grande and Wesley was having a
great time it was his birthday and
revealed that he and a friend are German
grandmasters when working with him on
the Catalan is if you need to be like a
rocket scientist to know who that is it
was it was pretty funny and then
somebody said Shh and I gave it to him I
wanted to just keep talking about it but
I decided not to talk about it
I know I know it was your wrong good
thing I actually thought about something
and didn't say it you know I held back
but yeah nice of you alright well here
Maxime does look like he's about to get
his first win in a long time that's for
politics if you're counting that's nice
he does seem to be converting it well
seven is interesting yeah and we're
gonna see the staircase the staircase
the brook of Rama Nakamura the staircase
look at this
this could be a look at Maxime is now
trolling hikaru a little bit who knows
the match is over and he's gonna milk
his victory here this is kind of fun I
enjoyed it I'm enjoying it
yes yeah yes
Brooks sack the car who plays it out to
mate King age now he's gonna sit and
then after King age 1687 mate well I've
seen that could disconnect in situations
like this before so it's true oh man
okay but he's got a very very healthy
lead and finds his match it's ticking
down under six I agree with ABS ABS mind
profit he promoted to a night
then it would have been fun it would
have been fun but it would have taken
him way too long the wind well um we're
back to our old back to our roots here
yeah if you didn't if you didn't get
enough of this and you were worried that
with six minutes left wouldn't see it
again here it is here's your grünfeld
again
I'm in remember tip and shimmy saying
you thought it'd be able to perform
better today but hikaru a beast yeah I
don't know that it's a lot of taking
away from Maxine as much as it is a Caro
being the animal that he is yeah it
didn't feel that way though you know
right at the start it would this match
was tied at nine games apiece again we
have 9,000 of you with us thank you so
much remember all your donations if you
decide one less time to stuff that car
was pockets with a few more dollars go
directly to the players that price one
bar you see but no this match was tied
at nine games apiece and since then it
has been just a complete me turn around
yeah he started to turn it around in the
late three-minute portion and then yep
basically continued his dominance in the
bullet but really I would say was the
three minutes second half that just
changed Bingley Ren was not in this
tournament rickety rickety cricket but
he was invited and actually wanted to
play confirmed but talked with him and
his manager and look we hope to have
ding in future years he was he was in
and then decided it was not going to
work with his schedule so ding is is he
just played the Olympia if he's still on
crutches where we saw Mike from the
Norway hip thing right yeah so he's
still walking around with with crutches
and he still can't lose he's a beast
he's a beast but you usually add a few
different types of players to speech s
Cheviot like having Duda in this year's
yeah that's it talk about talk about
surprises talk about things that have
gotten us super excited or what will be
the finals weekend of course November
30th and December 2nd yeah do to match
yeah
we're sure there's the there's the
opening of I've lost the match finally
opening I know I've lost the match here
comes the hippo we will see how this one
finishes while we have all of you
remember this is the last speech Chess
Championship match this corner finals
match upsets our field the final four is
decided and it will all go down the
first weekend of December and as we said
order finals have been set besides this
matchup and that means hey Cara Nakamura
will be moving on to face Levon Aronian
young christoph Duda be playing Wesley
so on the right side of the bracket
there so there you have it and what we
have all of you again some of you who
may not know that the next big event
here on chess comm is on Sunday for
myself along with jenshaw hottie and a
couple of poker superstars that you may
know will be having some awesome fun and
hand in brain and announcing the winner
to the Platinum pass tournament so make
sure you're here on Sunday very much
looking forward to that and hope you're
here good minutes left two minutes left
in this match we saw it and like
actually hang a piece there momentarily
as he it's very kind very comfortable
looks like a mismatch no that's just
another tactic Brooke c1 is pretty
pretty nice here probably he's gonna
just resign yeah and I'm not sure how
many games we'll we'll get but they've
been playing pretty fast probably one
more game if you goes the distance here
but from the from the start to the final
result it's it's so not reflective of
how the match was but I feel like I and
maybe others end up saying that a lot
about these speed chess matches because
it's such a momentum type of event that
when you have the momentum you're
capable of winning as we saw in akka
like four or five six points racking up
in a row and vice versa when you're
you're tilting or you lose a bad game
and
you let it get to you that can that can
easily make you lose multiple in the
road so you're able to create these
score lines which don't that aren't
reflective at all how close I'm not sure
they was
right
[Music]
yep the time is running out and NACA you
know ends up with a score line that that
showcases a dominant performance and in
a lot of ways it was you know it doesn't
matter how you get there whether it's
you know a general dominance or whether
you just pulled away at one point but he
and he did he did very impressive stuff
that's a nice finish there we go sorry
about that the last statement I said was
on mute but it was fun still fun to say
it all and a mantra pointed to it so the
world will never know and always wonder
what did Danny wrench say there that
didn't matter at all for the final 30
seconds of it but uh okay we we bring
back our our players the join us for
interviews the the one and only to one
and only Syriac our Nakamura and Maxime
Vashi in the drive can you hear us guys
he right next name you there hey Carl
can you hear us
I'm here we'll ask you Carl
don't think you can well um I Socorro
kinda works on his his sound there
maxime will will ask you okay obviously
this was a match that for the most part
felt just super close and either anytime
one of the players won two in a row it
seemed like the other person just
returned the favor and bounced right
back
the match was tied at nine games apiece
and and it looked like you got neither
player was gonna let the other one get
away get away too far but what happened
there as you had a couple bad games in a
row was it just was it just hard to
recover or do you feel like Hikaru maybe
figured something out in this this
constant Grunfeld battle you guys had
going on what was your what's your
assessment on where some of these games
started to get away from you Maxime it's
not to say as much was pretty close
ended and but since I'm probably I was
putting too much energy at the start and
by that point I was dirty I was already
fighting to keep in shape was actually
kind of played better so I think that's
that was a turning point but yeah
there's no question of who should win so
much in the end I mean this was very
dominating Baker of course in the
beginning there were a lot of mistakes
but then once he once he settled in
anyways um I think I think there was no
pretty much sure you feel the same way
that there were some mistakes in the
beginning but at some point there it
seemed toward the end of the
three-minute you kind of found your
groove and and settled in yeah I mean I
think at the start we both were making a
lot of mistakes I think I got some good
positions and I was blundering maxime
also had some good positions and it was
just very back and forth
but I think once I kind of sorted out
what I was doing this full this grew and
fell blind and I was able to basically
just get to like move 20 very easily -
took probably like I mean at least like
six or seven games before I got there
once I got to that point it just seemed
much easier so I wasn't having to spend
so much energy so I felt that the
position was very good so I mean I think
that was a turning point but it was
still very close and I mean I think
there was some point where it was still
only two games I think late and we
played this Italian and there's some
point where I started shaking my head
because Maxime is this d5 move after I
played rook a e8 and I think the one
that game would have been back to one so
um yeah I mean there was this deep pot
Bishop III de 6 and then ef7 Bishop III
that was waiting which I kind of saw but
I mean once once I didn't lose this game
I mean I think was pretty pretty smooth
sailing so I mean it's pretty pretty
close contrary to how so many of your
fans that follow you when you have long
blitz and bull sessions on chest confit
Caro you're known to play a lot of
different openings right a lot a lot of
b3 a lot of double V and keto you you
really mix it up and today right from
the get-go not only did you commit to
the seven Bishop g5 sidelines in the
Grunfeld but but you were stubborn right
and and you and so can you share a
little bit now the match is over was
that something you had prepared for this
and maybe felt like this was a good
choice and and did you maybe check in on
it at the break because you started
taking a slightly different approach in
Amman and I were speculating how much of
this was prepared by you yeah I mean I
knew that this full 96 line is supposed
to be bad for black so I mean that's
kind of the reason I kept playing it is
because I I knew that it was not the
most precise way to equalize and so kind
of I mean it at the start it felt like I
I mean I really start off that like this
this King walk to like each through
whatever it was so yeah that's just like
I thought the position was very good and
I mean I feel like if there's a position
where I don't really believe in it for
for my opponent and they keep playing it
then I might as well keep going into it
and so did you did you check on it you
said you had this bad game with King HP
the five minute did you kind of remind
yourself of some of your theory in
between the breaker or are we reading
too much into it did you not need to
yeah I mean I looked at a few things
during the break yeah I mean I did so
because I figured I'd keep getting until
I started winning game right that's kind
of what happened right okay well
interesting Maxine what were your
thoughts on that you said you were
spending a lot of energy and that maybe
that didn't pay off late in the match
was that kind of what you're referring
to you were defending these kind of
tough positions on the black side of
some really long run fields and that
kind of drained you mm no I just think
you know all the games see Italians are
the games I was spending a lot of energy
not to blunder sings well I still did
but to put as much pressure as I could
and I knew at some point I just didn't
have the stamina right come on
well you covered a lot of the questions
in terms of the the match Danny but I
guess another thing that just happened
was Norway chess just announced a pretty
interesting format so I guess to both of
the players sort of curious what your
thoughts are on a knowing Furman format
introducing Armageddon trying to produce
draws what are your guys thoughts on on
that format mm-hmm
you go first not sure yeah okay uh-huh
I mean I think it's interesting I
haven't looked at it very closely I
think it's you got like half point for
draw on the water then you got like one
point or half point for the rapid um so
I think it's an interesting idea I mean
I well I I don't know what exactly's
time control I think it's 2 2 hours flat
for the 2 hour for both sides yeah okay
so I mean I think this can work but I
still feel like if you have some game
that goes for hours it's gonna be you
know a little bit difficult on the
players so from that standpoint I don't
know about it but overall I think any
time there are new ideas that are being
tried it's it's a good thing so just
looking forward to see saying what
happens in Norway meeting Maxime yeah
I've already given some of my thoughts
actually today but I'll just read them
yeah like how I think it's always a good
idea to have new new for Mars being
tested and this might they will be in
step in the right direction
looking for for the future and oh well I
don't want to to be biased before we
test it but I feel like it's not
completely ideal 12 to give so much
important to a market and when you know
in general with trying to to to avoid
them other cost I mean trying to play a
lot of tight back games before it gets
to her so you know it will be
interesting to experiment but yeah I was
more enthusiastic with which Tom's ideas
that was if you make a draw you with
diverse colors you play rapid game and
if it's to to draw you you go back and
forth until you get a winner that that
actually I could I could like of course
when it comes to knowing chess I don't
think they have actually is a time to
implement this because of the TV format
but in general this I would like very
much to see experimented in one day
it's a good point yeah the the TV format
and we see Hikaru you're a great
multitasker which we speculated during
the match what what you were doing
speaking of things not just related but
I'm on led the way with a non match
question so I'll follow up what music
were you both listening to the car oh
you were really going there for a while
we speculated maybe some disco maybe
some ABBA well no I mean I doesn't have
that kind of rhythm to it um no actually
it was very traditional or just
listening to some rock it was mainly
Springsteen and Bon Jovi then a little
bit of their water creed and survival
you just described like my dream
playlist I loved it next thing and I
think I think at some point also you
could hear me I was actually on YouTube
and start playing Nirvana of course teen
spirit naturally so there's that as well
good good get pumped up song next thing
what about you it's hard to say simply
because those were stones for my
playlist
10 just like
all kind of artists or kind of is it
like American most American must be work
but some other stuff as well well
obviously we're this has been I think
maybe our most viewed match of the
quarterfinals and a lot of support for
you guys from the fans on both sides and
you guys you guys really entertained us
all day with some with some really
exciting motives we know it didn't work
out exactly how you want it to Maxine
but it karo congratulations you're
obviously moving on so we have to ask as
we always do to to bring this to a close
as you look at the quarterfinals being
done you now have Levon Aronian in the
semi-finals how do you feel about that
match up with Levon making it as far as
he ever has right having played in this
event since its beginning and have you
ever played Levon and this type of match
and in a bullet session like this yeah I
mean I think I played Levon a couple of
times on ICC like many many years ago
maybe like around 2002 or 2003 so it's
been a very very long time
I think of course alongs very strong but
I really I don't know what to expect in
the three in one and especially in the
bullet because I just I really haven't
seen what he's done I know he lost match
to yon but I haven't really followed
much so it's just gonna be very
interesting I think as I always say if I
keep it closed til the 3+1 and
especially the bolt and I think I'm
gonna have two chances as you look at
across the across the bracket there you
have your choice between young christoph
Duda or Wesley so obviously we know
we've seen due to really kind of come on
the on the scene here at least as far as
the global chess following is concerned
guys like you and Maxine probably have
seen due to coming for a while but he's
really started to make a name for
himself he upset both Carr yakkin and
Grichuk what do you think the chances
are he makes it all the way to the
finals yeah I mean I think he's not a
good shot I felt that Wesley was not
very convincing against Nita and that
match I mean the match went very
smoothly for him but I felt that he was
in quite a bit of trouble in many games
and Vitas simply didn't did put him away
like he should have so I think it's a
very close eye I have actually played do
quite a few time
just calm recently so I think he's got
good chances and I mean considering the
way that he's somehow pulled out that
match against burst shock
I kind of would like to play in the
final it'd be refreshing something
different yeah well we have a request
from our French broadcast remind all of
those of you who are here maybe you
didn't know that we cover these matches
in numerous different languages that
Maxime you maybe stick around and join
Kevin birdie on the official French
language coverage would you be willing
to no fair enough okay Mary you're
awesome hey Caro
you're also awesome thank you both for
being such great professionals we wish
you the best of luck of course in the in
the finals and semifinals at Caro and
Maxime thanks for sticking around
yeah thanks and tu a night off Monaco
yeah exactly how Danny to say that oh
you know what you're right I should have
mentioned that in fact I'm gonna do that
I actually had it now that I have you
both here both these guys are gonna be
in the Isle of Man and believe it or not
I was prepared for that because I've uh
I've got I've got it right up here the
whole players list of all of you guys
who are gonna be in the Isle of Man and
the main question is are you here are
you going easy I will be there believe
it or not I'm actually leaving my my
cage that my four children keep me
locked up and no more no more basketball
practices they can get their own ride to
school you know what I'm talking about
right I will be joining you guys and
we're gonna we're gonna try to do some
some special kind of stuff in between
each games and and try to really give a
lot of different content to the fans
working with you guys with interviews so
there you go if you didn't know what the
next big event is for chess calm besides
the poker one this weekend we've got the
Isle of Man International look at that
look at that list there that's crazy if
you guys ever played and opened this
strong before Hikaru and Maxime I mean
last year was the strongest but now
let's be very strong yep fungi can
remember so cut open that was similar in
France
also maybe one ship or tactician was
very strong as well but I mean when you
have 20 players are work 2700 or
something is you you're in for a good
fight well thanks for that reminder
Maxime and hers you guys are helping me
be a more profitable house so really
appreciate it yeah we're taking your
place at some at some point you both
will thank God right I mean I'm not
kidding about that and but that's for
another discussion and that gives now I
get to call you guys out and say now
when I hear it from all the fans and say
Danny
why aren't Maxime and Hakkar was dreamy
what am I supposed to tell them they
want more Hikaru at Maxine I mean okay I
mean I guess the first thing I first I
would answer that just just quickly
would be that I've just been trying to
focus on chests but for me for whatever
reason it seems like the more serious I
get the more I study the worse I do this
is oh maybe I'll search streaming more
cuz then my results might start actually
looking somewhat decent well we miss you
and thanks for thanks for the humour
Maxine what about you why arent you
streaming I should I definitely should
like to miss you guys I will but it just
you know days back to settle at home and
then it's already time to leave again so
I'm hoping to to find some time at least
before the end of the yeah I owe you you
guys that no it's we're just teasing but
seriously thanks for reminding that I'll
obey and I'll see you both there and you
guys probably get more followers even
when you're not streaming because people
are anticipating it that much so people
can go and follow your twitch channels
right now twitch TV /gn Picaro and yours
is twitch dot TV slash what is it is it
mvl chess or lyon beast
I suppose so I'm out of ten musics there
you go give it a alright well this has
been a lot of fun thanks guys
Maxine I'm gonna go ahead and kind of
bring the English call to a close but if
you stay on the zoom call Kevin will
grab you here in just a moment
of course all right
I guess alright bye